all right and we
are live the last word with lord cognito
anybody's
special friday and a special friday
guest episode 150
by me let's start with you for how you
doing man i am doing
excellent um running like a chicken with
my head cut off this morning literally
had to help a little bit with work so
hence the delay thank you guys for
tuning in a little bit later than normal
um but yeah got a fun announcement this
week
uh but before i even get into all of
that let's start the show because we got
a guest that is worthy of uh
definitely a special introduction so you
gotta bring them in baby
welcome to the last word episode 150.
big milestones are fun and celebrating
them with all of you is the best part
i want to thank each and every one of
you who have listened along the way and
got us this far
so thank you guys very much seriously
the guests the audience the
chat viewers everybody you guys have
been amazing thank you guys 150 is kind
of a big one
so definitely want to give you guys a
special shout out but
mythrax is going head-to-head with the
vex and guardians are traveling the vex
network tomorrow we travel back in time
to experience the vault of glass
and the raid that started many of us on
this epic journey splicing will continue
but we need to put a pin in this destiny
talk for just one second
our guest tonight is a special one this
guest embraces all things nerd and geek
culture
but can also likely outrun you on a
spartan course on the side
if he isn't staying in shape he is still
on his feet keeping his pharmacy running
smooth
when this family man does finally find
some time for himself
he enjoys all things games comics movies
and tv
so let's welcome a hardcore marvel fan
so much that even after the avengers
game
and a full mc watch mcu re-watched
probably twice
he even had to pick up the champions
card game a more hardcore star wars fan
than most of us out there because he is
an official member of the 501st legion
with his own full stormtrooper outfit
a traveler in the tardis even if he was
late to the party and
co-founder of guardian radio the first
and probably still longest ran destiny
podcast to date
and someone who can only be described as
guardian royalty and many would consider
an honorary member of the vanguard
let's welcome the one and only home for
your destiny news
tips and chatter mr dirk mr
dr mark turcotte
good man dude you just that that was i'm
blushing over here dude
like whenever i die you're going to
write my eulogies like no no family
members
no it's going to be a bonus i'm going to
put that in my will right now man it is
you my friend
wow dude that was a hell of a run down i
appreciate it man thank you
uh glad to be here with you guys though
it's been a while you know since i've
talked some destiny so
uh yeah glad glad to be here guys and
and wow i mean that was an intro man
holy [ __ ]
i got goosebumps
honestly like from meeting you and all
the guys of guardian radio guardian khan
you're one of the reasons this podcast
even exists so
very special to celebrate 150 with you
you guys went for almost 300 you started
it before the damn game even came out
yeah i mean it's it's it's a piece of
destiny history for sure so
definitely happy to have you here
joining us for one of our milestones and
maybe someday we'll pass your totals but
we got a ways to go
we got years to try and catch that one
no not really though
what did we end off at i think it was
like 277 like we got did we get the 290s
to go so if we make it to the end of
destiny we might catch up all right
all right i think some people are
knocking down our door though i think
probably you know ign is probably their
destiny community podcasts or even
playing
right probably yeah yeah probably yeah
but
yeah man we i mean we were doing the
show a year and a half before the game
came out i mean it was it's crazy to
think back to that how we uh
you know just talked about literally a
screenshot i saw on twitter because i
still follow like a lot of the destiny
community just kind of see what's going
on you know it's all on my twitter feed
and somebody pulled up an image of like
look at this old image and it has a
fallen
and a guardian and a cabal like what
could that mean i'm sitting there
thinking like
you probably go back to guardian radio
episode six and we spent like 45 minutes
breaking down that you know that that
concept art because that was all that we
had you know we didn't have anything
else back then
uh it's crazy man now you guys set the
standard i mean i i just missed the
camaraderie
obviously like he said it was one of
those things that like you know
coming into destiny i didn't know where
to go as far as information and because
of so much depth to the game you didn't
realize it
was like podcasts like yours who you
know i learned so much and just how the
structure of you guys did it you had fun
always had like amazing guests so yeah
definitely got a silly we gotta give you
the roses why you could smell them you
know say it because
it was definitely you know a a milestone
pillar for me
as one of my regular rotations and like
i was telling you before we we
officially went live
like my first guardian con which was at
the time destiny con
where i met e you know out in the tampa
sun
i'm like damn i love this game you know
i want to meet people who have the same
passion i do and i get there
and the first booth i get to i see was
there yet
great i was like oh man you guys are all
set up you're checking my hair you
probably shook a thousand head
you know people heard this in the kind
of the pre-show but i got a new wallet
for christmas this year and i was kind
of going through it and
cleaning it out you know you get that
real thick wallet that you always get
because you're just accruing things you
know over the years
and ibontas's business card was still in
my wallet man
you know i was just like man i had a you
know a bunch of cards from there but i
just still remember abanta's coming up
and saying hey
i'm starting this youtube channel and
giving me his card and you know here
look at you guys now man i mean
you guys are doing this this is great um
it's pretty good
yeah lots of fun man lots of fun man so
let me ask you a quick question before
we get into it
like so now you've been away you know
saying kind of doing
your thing now you know and one thing i
did notice was um this enthusiast life
and stuff like that
just also just messing around with
different aspects you know i'm saying
like comic geek culture
other video games like how has that
experience been for you
now that you've been away for a little
bit yeah it's man it's been
probably the most freeing and just
fun time i've had podcasting i mean
guardian radio for what it was you know
with the time and place i mean it still
was an incredible journey and i mean i
always look back at it fondly and we'll
never forget i mean there's so many
memories within that
but like the reason when i kind of go
back to when we started guardian radio
was
prior to that i was doing a just generic
video game podcast for
for uh there was a couple websites i
worked for aval.com then moved over to
game insider magazine and then we moved
over to guardian radio and
the appeal of guardian radio was i don't
have to cover everything you know it was
like all i need to do is focus on
what's happening in the game this week
and it was like wow you know we don't
need to be playing all these games and
of course we just kind of struck it
while it was hot because there was no
podcast yet so guardian radio just kind
of took off because we were all
there was yeah so you know as the other
shows started coming out we were just
the ones that had been there and
you know had a great relationship with
bungie so it just was it was a perfect
ride
but as the years went on you know it
kind of got to the point where it was
like
there's all these other things you know
that i love but like i just felt
strapped and kind of
i only have to be talking about destiny
you know there was always that feeling
of i have to be playing destiny every
week i have to be logging in
and so stepping away from it it was just
kind of freeing it was like hey i can go
back and play a lot of these games that
i missed
a lot of these games that maybe i played
an hour or two of but never were
able to complete and then i mean i've
always had a love of comics and always
had
you know just that geek side of me and
that and so with the enthusiast life i
actually started i think we were doing
guardian radio i was doing with my buddy
chris
but where the show is now it's literally
it's a daily show
monday through friday i do it it's like
15 to 20 minutes and
i mean i just talk about you know
whatever i want what do you think would
you think of just the term enthusiast
life it's like
enthusiasts is like what are you
enthusiastic about and literally i mean
my listeners just
are all people like-minded like me that
are into some of the same things that i
am
and you know we i've just been having
fun you know talking about video games
talking about comics
and you know every friday with the
disney plus shows the star wars shows
the marvel shows i'm kind of breaking
those down and
you know uh comics all that stuff it's
it's been a lot of fun doing that show
and
and
you know like i said it's just it's
freeing you know i don't need to focus
and pinpoint at one thing you know which
is
which i will say though and i one of the
advice or some of the advice i always
give to people when it comes to
podcasting
is you know try to find your niche
and that's what guardian radio did it
was that we were able to say hey
nobody's doing this we're able to
log into this and here's here's what we
can deliver to an audience and so
the enthusiast life i was able to take
that audience that i built there
and carry some of them over to this nice
where if you know if i just tried to
start the enthusiast life off
today with no history of guardian radio
i mean it probably
you know it'd get lost in the mix man
there's so many podcasts out there now
you know which i'm not discouraging
people from podcasting believe me it's
fun
and do it for the fun of it it is great
but you know i don't think i would be
able to
you know have the success i have with it
now had i not done guardian radio you
know
so enough enough but you got e uh
no i mean it's just kind of like for all
the stuff that you've been listening
through it's like you are kind of
probably
in heaven with regards to everything
that is out there in the world of
entertainment lately
like totally i mean growing up i mean
you're i think you're around our age i
don't know if you're older or younger i
always forget but i feel like you're
kind of close
uh i'll be 40 next week let's put it
that way i'll drop it i'll drop you
literally you're between us but yeah you
look good for 40 we're all not doing too
happy so
yes but yeah it's like part of growing
up especially even like
the whole nerd culture star wars gaming
stuff was not as cool and now it's
no literally everywhere and just like
completely embraced mandalorian like
overtakes twitter and
like the news every so often with
something like baby yoda so
for you is like it's just got to be so
awesome to be able to jump in
and as much of i gotta say like your
star wars
like fanfare is amazing to watch because
you've got the full stormtrooper outfit
you're part of the league man so i
wanted to hear
just like where are you in the world of
star wars right now because i know this
is normally not what we talk about every
so often but it's like
your star wars world right now has got
to be like the best it's ever been it is
man you know i'll tell you
there are a lot of people who and of
course like after rise of skywalker and
even last jedi i mean the star wars
fandom just
went south quick online i mean there
were people like me who just
take it for what it is and enjoy it and
just want to absorb everything but then
there are the purists who say
you know jj abrams killed star wars or
you know whatever you want to say
but for me i mean everything that's been
coming out is just expanding on the lore
of star wars and
you know to get a little deep into kind
of the creators i mean now obviously
everybody knows george lucas
the guy who's kind of at the helm of it
right now is david and he's the one that
did a lot of the clone wars stuff
yes and dude i put all my faith in
felony the clone wars and what he
created with that was fantastic
what they've been doing with mandalorian
is great the bad batch for what it is
i'll say you know some people i urge
people even if you haven't watched clone
wars go check that out because it's
giving you a glimpse of the beginning of
the empire so each episode you're
getting these little nuggets
of like hey that's how they did that
like how did the empire switch from
clones to
just regular people being stormtroopers
we're learning that how are they able to
convince
planets to just go along with being a
part of the empire and not
you know basically rebel against them
even though we do get the you know the
rebels down the line like
that show is great and like you know the
the new books they're putting out they
they're started a whole new era called
the high republic
which i'm loving this is taking place
between like basically the old republic
and the stuff that we know
i think yoda's like 300 years old in
this which seems like a lot but it's
kind of like in between you know he's
like middle-aged and it's related
you don't see him much but all the new
jedi they're introducing and
those authors are have been given the
liberty to like explore the force so if
you're bit real big into the force or
the way they're describing it and all
that and so dude like you said abanta
says
as a kid what we're living in now i
never could have imagined and
perfect example to switch it to marvel
real quick was oh god when i went to see
um yeah you know end game and
we're in that theater and i don't i
don't want to spoil it but i hope most
people have seen endgame by this point
fair warning listen stop listening for
like 20 seconds casey says what i think
he's going to
and those portals open dude i was
literally in tears like tears of joy and
my wife is looking at me like what the
hell is wrong with you i'm like
if you would have told me when i was
seven years old you know at the comic
shop reading these comics when i mean i
have my original copy of the infinity
gauntlet
that i would see something like this and
all these heroes come together on screen
in the way that we've had all these
movies built up to it
i never in a million years would have
thought it and here it is right now i
mean it's
and you just you never could imagine i
mean i remember like when the first
x-men movie was coming out it was like
oh there's going to be an x-men movie
and
that's cool and now we live in a world
where it's like just
every other week there's i mean today
there's a new marvel show today people
may not know about it's on hulu modoc
it's like a robot chicken style show
it's a comedy show but it's like
here's yet another marvel show that we
have coming out today and i look at like
my kids you know there's a whole
generation of kids that are growing up
with the new star wars
but even like my kids their star wars is
now marvel
like the marvel hero there's gonna be
like we the 501st
you know as i'm a part of as a storm
trooper we go to these you know uh star
wars celebration we do all these
conventions and that
there's gonna be people just going to i
guarantee it very soon i mean there's
comic conventions
there's gonna just start being an mcu
celebration at some point
somebody's gonna do it because really
there's more movies than that than there
is in star wars
and plus you have the comics and i mean
it's
ah it's crazy like it's waking up every
day with a smile on my face because of
it all right oh yeah it's like you
mentioned that one line for in-game
the the line and when it happened like
literally
when you see it wiggle and then it's
like the pickup and like you see
reactions in the theater i had the same
thing
i lost my mind my wife's probably doing
the same thing next to me like
this is what he cheers out loud for like
that those are those moments but when
it's like when he says like
the word and you're like oh yeah it's
just everybody loses their mind but it's
like
that is i mean from like you know the
the 90s
x-men tv show with the awesome animated
like all of those things you grow up and
then now with the t's of like
phase four looks like just incredible
blowing of what they can go
cuts in there like what are we like
you're bringing some of these characters
in that like
never would have thought we'd be getting
a movie let alone a series where we're
gonna get
hours of content with these these
characters i mean it's incredible man
and then it's wild yeah and then captain
falcon winter soldier
well yeah however you want to say all
those i was kind of screwed that one up
but yeah it's like
man just even that serious six episodes
you're like could not be
more of a polar opposite show from one
division both very cool experiences
yep the monologue at the end of captain
like a falcon was just like
damn like and they're even able to use
marvel in those types of ways and i'm
just like
that's really cool too to see everything
it's everywhere and it's really
really awesome you know what i will say
about this too and one thing i think you
know when
i mean just in general falcon in the
winter soldier a lot of people were like
i don't want politics in my marvel shows
or you know why are you doing
has anybody ever read a marvel comic
book go back to stanley and jack kirby
the original
the original theory of marvel was the
world outside your window those guys
were in new york city
and they were writing literally about
the world inside outside their window
that's why the x-men exists man like
x-men was all about like
the you know the fight for like racial
injustice but they put it in in terms of
mutants and then you have
discrimination yeah you had all of that
and so it's like you know when you look
at the falcon in the winter soldier
number one
that storyline even though it was very
different and you know but but sam
picking up the shield and becoming
captain america
was in the comics years ago you know and
so like that
and they they address all of that there
so it's not like this is new
that's what marvel has always been doing
but now it's on such a grand stage and
more people are seeing it
but it's great and it's it there could
not have been a better time
to do things like this and start putting
this stuff out there it's
not we love it man i'm completely with
you when you you said you both you guys
got you know emotional doing those parts
it's because
you know we're older we remember as kids
you're buying those books you
you're watching those you know those
smaller cartoons and things
and your dream is like yo it would be so
cool on the big scale
and then let's be honest we also
suffered because we also had a lot of
bad comic book movies
so so now you have this culmination of i
forgot how many years we'll say 12 15
years of
of mcu or whatever whatever 12 years i
think it's been right yeah
so like and to see everything woven
so perfectly with the little nuances
with the call backs you know
on your left all these things and then
you get to the moment
and you're like man like they did it
like they
really didn't cause you we so we're so
used to them
[ __ ] most fumbling the ball and you're
just like
no this is beautiful and for me i'm just
like you mark
i had those infinity gauntlet books i
used to tell people this is one of the
greatest stories in comics
like you know you guys see dinosaurs
you're not gonna be ready and
and to see it all come together you know
for the most part
almost intact with the characters they
had and everything like that but yeah
i wish i'm with you it was true i'll
tell you i mean amazing
i know we're not talking destiny here
people don't like
you here's something to point out too
kind of where we are and you know end
game that moment was so impactful
because of you had
all the movies prior to it right yes a
little example of something that in my
opinion has kind of failed even though i
didn't you know i
enjoyed the movie for what it was is
mortal kombat oh look cool as hell for
the
they're doing the fatalities and all
that stuff is cool but it was so rushed
and so now having disney plus and and
not even just lindsay plus even you know
netflix all these streaming services
they can have a series
where it's not just an hour and a half
two hours a movie yes you can have a
series that's eight hours long and build
those characters and that's why the
moment at the end of end game worked
because you had that history where
mortal kombat it was just like here's
this character here's this character
here's
they don't even have a tournament in the
movie
that should have been an hbo max series
and i hope they do that i hope we have
the movie now i hope we get a series so
they can focus on the characters and do
that
but you know but we live in an age now
where they can do that and like that's
even more exciting like
i i was i've been equating the disney
plus shows in the movie and how they're
going to do the marvel movies to
wrestling now it's like
you watch wrestling week in week out
there's your monday night raw there's
your series right there's your your
marvel
series and then you're gonna go see the
pay-per-view in the theater and that's
going to be when they're all going to
come together
that's it they've turned marvel into
wrestling and that's why you're going to
go
get your pay-per-view by going to the
movies like that talk about coming full
circle that's an impressive impressive
there you go link up there nice yes
but outside of even just like the screen
there's another usual smaller screen
unless you're just playing on the big
screen
what like so obviously i mean you lived
in the world of guardian already you
played destiny for a while but you
mentioned these games you missed and i
was the same way like covering destiny i
was like
playing so much you know i played breath
of the wild for like five hours jump
back in destiny i played horizon zero
and on for like five hours jump back in
destiny so
all these things that you've missed and
like either gone back to what are the
standouts that you either
missed or that you're even like less
destiny has given you more time to enjoy
now what games have you
caught back up on that have been major
standouts or what has kind of got you
hooked as of late
i will say like during the time of
guardian radio like the nintendo
like breath of the wild i mean i
definitely said guardian radio or
destiny aside same thing with like you
know mario come like i'm just a nintendo
kid
years ago but uh the games that i really
jumped into there's
was just mmos man like and i think you
know i played a little bit of world of
work warcraft when it launched but never
really got into like raiding or
i don't even think i ever really hit i
think i maybe hit level 50 on one
character but never had like a group to
run with or anything but
kind of getting that experience in
destiny of having that
weekly group week in week out made me
want to get into mmo so there's two mmos
and one i actually was playing a little
bit while we were doing um guardian
radio but the first is elder scrolls
online
i started it on i bought it on pc when
it first launched
switched over to console because a lot
of my uh clan mates from destiny were
getting it on console
they all fell off quickly so i jumped
back to pc and um
i mean do the pc version of that game
number one it looks
better than the console version even
though they are getting the next gen
upgrades but having the ability to put
um like mods into it so you know like
just number one to have a map
the game doesn't have a map you have to
actually hit a menu button to look at
the map sort of
constantly have the map on the screen is
a big deal right but you can also
populate that map with dungeons and you
know things that you're missing but
um that game is great i would urge
people who play destiny
to maybe check that out especially if
you have game pass because why not i
mean it's not going to hurt you it's
free
um because a lot of their dungeons as of
late the newer dungeons over the last
couple of releases they put out have
mechanics in them and especially when
you start playing those on veteran mode
everybody has to play their role which i
mean it's typical where you have a
healer
two dps in a tank um but it's not as
strict as like uh world of warcraft or
final fantasy
but the mechanics that they're adding to
the dungeons are super fun and remind me
a lot of raids
destiny raids so if you're into you know
you like rating and that in destiny give
elder scrolls online a chance and don't
be intimidated by being an mmo
because i mean you can play that game
just basically solo like everybody's
clamoring where's elder scrolls six i
need elder scrolls six and i'm like
dude elder scrolls six seven eight nine
and ten has been out for the last you
know five years and you're just missing
it like
there is so much story content and elder
scrolls online
it's incredible so yeah they've been
putting in a ton of the uh
the like i said dr borwin skyrim stuff
in the world
just kind of implanted them in there
yeah that community is
very big and they've been yeah they've
been growing man the support has been
tremendous what does it z
and those are actually yeah it does that
game yep and you can you know every
class you can play they're they're
constantly switch out all your skills
and abilities and it's action-based so
it's not like world of warcraft where
you're
you know tab targeting and just hitting
looking at your cooldowns it's actually
action based you're dodging you're
blocking
yeah so it's great it's got a little
something for everybody in it so if you
haven't played that check it out and the
pvp is actually a lot of fun too it's
big massive open world pvp where
basically you roll up on a
castle or a stronghold one team is in
there and you're literally
pounding barricading the door in you're
shooting catapults at it half the time i
just go and stand on top of the hill and
just watch
because it's just it's just awesome
there's an emo you pull out a chair i
pull out a little wind chair my guy's
just sitting there just watching these
guys just
wrecking each other down there um but
then the other game the other mmo that i
spent god i mean now i've been playing
for over 300 hours but it was
to get from where the very beginning to
the end it took me a little over 260
hours was final fantasy 14.
that was a game all throughout us
playing destiny everybody kept saying
that game just keeps getting better
keeps getting better you gotta play that
game
and um i just shortly it was the summer
after we finished uh guardian radio so
it would have been what 2019.
um i just said you know what i'm going
to give it i tried to give it a go a
couple times
and i just jumped in and do the story of
that game
the the initial like 1 to 50 which is
the
realm reborn stuff is kind of the
initial stuff is very cut and dry they
have streamlined it a little bit
but once you get beyond that and get to
the newer expansions that game
i'm gonna say right now i mean i love
final fantasy vii for the story even
final fantasy iii
which is really final fantasy six great
stories final fantasy 14 is the best
final fantasy story
bar none dude i promise you because you
are so
dude i'm telling you six guys
it is incredible that and then on top of
that you know i mean
it still is very much kind of in its
trope of
holy trinity of healer you know dps and
tank
and it is you are on cooldowns but once
you kind of learn your rotations and
start going through those dungeons
again as the newer dungeons have come
out like elder scrolls they put more
mechanics in there so you're all having
to work together
to take down dungeon bosses and uh i
mean if you want to just play
just the story which it's always weird
saying this mmo has an incredible story
because you already think of that with
an mmo
um but you can pretty much play solo and
just queue in with dungeons from
you know one to level 80 where we are
now and
it'll take you well over 250 hours
probably more i mean now end walkers
come out which which is intimidating to
a lot of people and that
that's one of the problems that game has
is that they're so deep into it
you can buy a bypass and immediately get
level 80 but it's like
you don't want to do that and then i was
on the fence when i first started
playing it
but everybody kept saying like just just
play through it just get through it just
go through it yeah just stick with it
and um that's cool but
it's awesome it's great you branch out
on that man
really cool really cool so you've been
watching destiny a little bit from the
distance for the past
man checking out what's going on have
you uh stepped your foot
in there recently i have i mean every
expansion fall expansion
i've jumped into um because to me i've
always loved the
give me a new space to explore like that
the exploration of destiny that i've
always loved that
and i mean we talked about this a little
bit but that's why i've always liked the
older
you know like season pass model where we
were getting like a drop of
say what you want about chris of osiris
but it was a new space but then we got
warming i loved warming it like reminded
me of
the original destiny content you know
but it was a new space it was mars
new areas to go and just discover stuff
so with like beyond light and forsaken
and all that
obviously you know i've kind of jumped
into those um
the new season pass model i actually
didn't buy the season pass at all last
year
um this year i did um because the last
season i liked
i actually really enjoyed that game mode
um in the
what was it called battlegrounds yes
and i remember i mean i saw you know
afterwards like i played it i remember
tweeting something like this is great
they're just constantly throwing enemies
and then of course that became what was
the buzzword
of uh
but like you could really feel it in
that first battleground like i just
remember you kind of
towards the end you turn that corner and
there's like just those massive
ball spheres on the horizon just like
being chucked at you
and i was like this is just awesome and
so
i really enjoyed replaying that um but
you know the the season model for me
it's not really giving us a lot of new
spaces i mean we're getting these new
activities but they're
kind of like playing override this week
you know i jumped in not only just
because i knew i was gonna be on the
show but i bought the season pass i'm
like oh let me let me see what this is
about
and it's just i'm not gonna say it feels
the same
but it just kind of is it's like just
kind of like we're just kind of doing
the same thing but we're throwing some
little gambit mechanics where i'm
grabbing some moats
and kind of tossing them in this thing
and then we're fighting a boss and it's
and for me i'm not because i'm not as
invested in the game like i used to be
i'm not all about upgrading to get all
these new mods
which really seems to be that's the
thing right as you're upgrading your
your
uh your item your artifact and it's to
unlock all these new mods which then
you can take into the new raids and
stuff like that and for me right because
i'm not playing it like that anymore
nope it's not really doing it no i get
that yeah so that that's where this new
model for me is kind of just
fizzling out a little bit you know but
it's understandable with the team size
you know they don't have enough
developers there to keep going with it
so i was gonna say
like for sure i mean even for me like
i'll start the season kind of hard for a
week or two but even when you look at
the seasonal calendar for
me i'd be like it it feels like it's
going to be a
tuesday for me it's going to be my
tuesday log in we've got the expunge for
like the next six weeks we have the
couple weeks of
override on different locations but i
was even just trying to grind out the
splicer gauntlet for override and i'm
sitting there just like
the only thing i can do to upgrade this
thing is override so i'm playing
override for days
like you know straight and then after a
while i'm just like this is literally
all i'm doing i'll like
go to two strikes cause they're like the
the thing of the week
you know you get your ether from there
you buy your keys just like you did with
the hammer so it's hammer 2.0 slightly
better quality of life but
i'm just sitting there like override
over it hey occasionally i got the
network anomaly over and then it's like
and
so i'm looking forward to the expunge
mission to see a little bit of the story
of progression go forward
so it was like for the activities for me
i'm with you like
you know my tuesday log in check out the
battlegrounds what i've really enjoyed
has been like
the like these last couple of seasons
like beyond light set up some cool stuff
but these two seasons of
voice over npc interactions and the
stories this season have been
game changing and i was like from you
coming back from destiny 1 and like
we're all lost when we finish the
campaign of destiny 1 like what just
happened
versus now when it's literally just like
plastered in game in front of you i was
just kind of curious your thoughts of
how the status progressed and what's
your hope for kind of going forward
i mean that's one thing that i think if
anything they've done they've obviously
found that out like the best way to do
that now
you know um i think having these little
i mean there's almost like a star wars
holocron right that they're kind of
giving you you know
probably not as much of an investment
for them to you know put animators on
creating those
i think it's great for them to do that
because before this content would have
been hidden behind
grimoire cards right you would have had
bifen and uh
you know mylan basically decode these
things for you now you have it's
literally like you said it's plastered
in front of you this is
every week you log in you're going to
get the new story bits and that's great
i think
you know the fact that they've been able
to find this way to do that
is is awesome i mean even even the
little things where now you know you're
going up to the characters i mean
destiny 2 has been doing this but where
the characters are actually standing in
front of you then it kind of does that
slow pan and then like
you know the stuff comes up on the side
like even that has been you know
having destiny to do that over destiny
one has been been nice
um you know for me in terms of the story
being that i'm not vlogging and every
week you know i am
behind on the story if you want to say
you're kind of just like all right you
know this is cool i mean
seeing characters come back you know
this this week has been kind of cool you
know characters that haven't been there
for a while
um but you know um i think if you're
someone like myself who's been away from
it for a while you come back and you're
just like all right well the vex now
have made everything go dark
i like the aesthetic of you know kind of
the little what do you call like little
cyber
blips and things kind of over there
which is cool
um but uh you know i don't really know
where i think for me where i
would want the story to go is like i
just want the darkness to come man like
i want to see
what is in these ships like for real
because that goes back to destiny one
you know this is great and we're
we're taking our time to get there but
um is the witch queen gonna deliver that
that's a good question i don't know are
we going to just kind of get back into
this this now steady stream of
here's your season here's your activity
unlock these mods and upgrades and
that's it like i don't know yeah that
was a good point okay good evening no no
no no
go ahead you know i'll just say it's a
good point because um
you know especially from your
perspective obviously as a heart as a
hardcore person that now stepped away
and then you're kind of getting back in
i think what's interesting is
what you said about how you were more of
a fan of the expansion model as opposed
to
the seasonal model because as a hardcore
person to play destiny consistently
every day
you know it is a struggle for this type
of drip feed content for a lot of people
i can imagine yeah i think what the
transition for us
e has been i know i was rough on it too
because i didn't adapt well to it
i was just like i want more this is not
enough and you know i want the big
expansion but like you said earlier
beautifully is that you know they're on
their own obviously
you know resources and development is
not the same you know what i mean
so we have to change the expectation a
little bit but what i found now is now
i've got this nice balance where like he
said
log in on a tuesday i do my story beat
stuff i get my narrative stuff done
right do any of any any cool weapon
farming and stuff like that that i do
see
and bills i do see i'll i'll go get but
then after that like
by thursday friday you know i'm already
like okay i can play other stuff now
you know yeah so now i'm in this like
nice little balance where i'm
actually able to play other things and
get be productive because let's be real
with destiny's good
destiny takes your soul oh it totally
does yeah
like it is a selfish relationship it
doesn't want you talking to anybody else
it was you focused on the goal so i know
what you mean
with that balance and stuff like that
and and being away
and and just how you adapt with it you
don't completely understand what other
games and stuff like that
yeah and they i mean they've said before
that you know they didn't want destiny
to be
your only game right you know they
they've come out and said that before
but i think they've said that before
they finally came out and said
we're considering destiny and mmo yes so
it's like all right if you want to be an
mmo i mean you got to kind of have
not just although these last two seasons
adding in these these audio logs and
that that is things that are in mmos
you're getting maybe a weekly a new
weekly quest or a new something so
they're
they're getting there like it's it's
it's it's coming and
essentially you know i've kind of been
laughing because i'm i remember talking
about this on guardian radio of like
would anybody pay a monthly fee for
destiny and everybody's like no no no
you're paying for the season pass like
you essentially you are i mean it's
getting spread out
right i mean and then you're getting in
a little bit of a cheaper discount but
ultimately you are i mean you're paying
somewhat of a monthly fee by buying that
season pass
yeah um but you know i don't know i mean
how would how would you guys feel about
that would you how would you feel if you
were paying
i mean elder scrolls online you don't
have to pay for a monthly fee you get
you get the content you want to buy the
get the new dungeons in that you can
either buy them piecemeal
or you can pay a monthly fee and get
access to it and you get some other
little perks in that
final fantasy you do have to pay a
monthly fee for that game but they are
bringing you constant content
how would you feel if destiny or bungie
came out and said
maybe i mean i'll say ten dollars but
let's even say five dollars
how would you feel if they promised more
content
maybe more story missions and not just
these little audio logs how would people
feel about that
i was like i hate the term celebrity
slope um but it becomes a very
interesting discussion of
you think about what we get for ten
dollars in a season
and the bar that they've set with that
to be for ten dollars the size of their
studio and we see what they can do
i don't know they would i mean they
talked about like building their studio
like almost two and a half times bigger
studio hiring a bunch more people
obviously
to fill out that giant space if it got
to the point where that place was full
and they had teams that were like you
know seasons and weeks and stacked upon
like
that type of consistency because the bar
they set now for me
is kind of a tuesday thing and i'm like
how much more do i need to live in this
thing for a seasonal model
because the season for ten dollars if
you break down even what you get like
you know for ten bucks it's not bad
we're getting a new activity
little decent amount of voice lines we
get a story we got you know
not new spaces but now we got the vex
network we're gonna have the expunge
mission
whatever the epilogue activity is gonna
be in any like you know spicy stuff in
between
it's not a bad value for ten dollars me
it like kills me when i log in and i'm
like
i get my one page in my email of the
story like once a week
when i get like i'm like all right cool
i read page two you gotta wait six days
god
okay i want more and i want it now and
that's that's always my
issue of like again same thing with the
expansion model is
some people want to just consume like
you know i want to play the game pretty
hard enjoy everything that's there
and then maybe if you do release
something cool like the whisper the worm
used to do
here's this one thing come back play
crazy and then you can take your break
but that
they don't they d as you said they don't
want it to be your game all the time but
then they set this up to where you
literally want to log in every week now
with the seasonal challenges if you miss
a week like
hey scorched is this week if you don't
play it this week it might be five weeks
to get
that triumph or any of those things so
it's this weird they're kind of playing
both sides of
we don't want you playing all the time
but we want you playing once a week make
sure make sure you log in once again
like shtick and it's like okay so if i
did 10 bucks a month or five bucks a
month so that turns the seasons into
15 roughly if it was a little bit more i
wouldn't mind but there's also people
who are like i need you to justify why
that's there
and as it's seven years into this saga
the only way i think they could probably
justify that is if they do a destiny
whatever follows this 10 years if they
set it up as a different model their
bigger studio
and they can commit to you know grander
things
and they're like it is going to be a
true mmo because we've decided to go
down this route it's less about pvp
there's more pve but we're gonna go
you know not quite world of warcraft but
it's that scale and it's gonna be you
know five dollar a month fee for
consistency for us
less eververse stuff more in the game
however they balance that it's
like the justification would kind of
need to be presented up front
because it's been seven years of not
having to do that but even though you
said the seasonal model
turns around and is basically one it's
just they mask it as something else so
it's always
happening yeah so it's like we're
literally paying it yeah you are you
don't even mention tess
and transmog yeah
clearly well but i mean that's the thing
too they've transitioned to almost a
free to play model right i mean the game
you can essentially get it for free so
you know they do have to have those
hooks in there to make some money to
have kind of constant flow because not
everybody is either buying the games
you know buying well buying the stories
if you want to say right because really
that's all you're buying now is the
stories right
essentially because because if you just
had destiny too didn't you get access
to europa not the story content yeah you
just go to the space right
right right so it's like they're giving
people some new content
the free to play players and it's really
that story content that you're kind of
buying so
i don't know man it's it really is a
give and take when it comes to a free to
play
model like that you gotta you know keep
the free to play players happy but you
also gotta
keep your uh you know your whales if you
want to say or people that are
constantly playing the game you got to
keep them happy too
yeah and you know bungie i mean they've
been doing it for a while now and
they're i think they're just kind of
starting to get to the point where
they're maybe finding
you know that they're maybe kind of
hitting their stride a little bit but
then you see
things like the armor synthesis and
transmog which
we've been talking about since probably
episode one of guardian radios
yeah and dude like i mean i had another
friend that was like well they're giving
you like you know five of them and you
can do one
and i'm like man but like they know
people wanted this forever like
for some people destiny is not a fashion
show but for a lot of people an mmo
is and like if you're going to say this
is an mmo and for me personally
it kind of always has been like i just
if i like like the helm of saint 14 i
wore
almost all the way through destiny one
regardless because i just i loved
playing you know my
my uh was it sentinel titan and like
that's what i played and i always
was popping my wards and i just like to
have that helmet on because i like the
way that it looked
yeah and now you know with transmog it's
like if i wanted that
you know even though i would have got
the free one that season i would have
had to work to maybe get
another you know what the new helmet
that's kind of replaced right same 14.
um but then in the same sense the other
thing that i was kind of chuckling about
was seeing some of this was
that was my initial impression but then
the more i thought about it i was like
you know you're seeing all these people
saying like you gotta spend 400 hours to
get every armor piece and everything and
it's like
do you really want to do that like are
you are you gonna wear
all 100 helmets like no you're really
doing this for that one helmet that you
like
two or three helmets that you like and
you know what maybe next season it'll be
there or
don't transmog anything do it if you
want to wear the helmet put the freaking
helmet on in the top or walk around and
then when you go back into your strike
switch back over so i actually kind of
see both sides of the
the coin with that but it still is a
little bit silly that they just made it
so obtuse to do it this way it's like
it's actually like grinding for it's
crazy yeah it's crazy
that was the thing i think as soon as we
heard about it um we
because we had travis on for that one
completely but it is the whole idea as
you said before the game
even came out mmos transmog i mean you
have games like anthem that came out and
basically flopped said to say but also
on the other side
you could paint your yeah javelin
to kingdom come you could make that
thing look whatever shader whatever
color different armor pieces and there
were some things that you could buy for
different like textures and stuff
but the idea of everybody wanted
transmog for so long
and then it finally comes out in the
worst possible way that i think any game
has ever done it you're just like
how do you do that to the people who've
been asking this for so long and you're
like
i get you either have it crazy grindy
you have the pay wall somewhere in
between but it's just like
they made it so un unimaginably
unfun it's just like i don't i don't
somebody was just like okay so let's do
this thing
we need to add three more currencies at
the grind like somebody somewhere
screamed and
apparently got listened to and you're
just like i don't know how this happens
because
no other game i think has made it this
ridiculous you either pay for it
or it's something but they just they
have both and it's those weird moments
where
bungie does great things with like the
pressage mission i'm like i'm literally
playing
only in the movie amazing oh yeah which
was great i did play through that man
that thing is awesome so good and then
you turn around and see an announcement
like this and you're like
just like facepalm moment you're like
how do you do both how and it's like i
know there's different teams and
different decisions and finances and
business i get all of those things but
sometimes man it's it's very
questionable so
yeah i agree i think um just
to finish this topic up is that i am a
firm believer especially with transmog
with how
it was not received well like it was it
was blood in the street
people people were like no this is not
it and
i'm a firm believer that they know this
right they know the developers
know this most likely it's not going to
go well to community
so i'm a firm believer that internally
the financial people say look oh totally
man oh yeah this is what has to happen
we know the community wants this
this is one of the highly requested
features from like you said from when
mark was doing from d1 that this is one
of the highly requested features
you better figure out a way to monetize
this
with our big goals that we've got we've
got this australian studio we've got
these new ips coming up we know what
they're working on
call matter or whatever whatever i'm a
firm believer the business
people have made a stand and say no
you cannot now at some point they may
reverse it and may pull
back a little later down the road what's
money's accumulating yeah
but not right now because for as much as
we push let's be honest and
in destiny and bungee history they for
the most part acquiescer says you know
what
we were a little heavy-handed oh yeah
they listen to the community yeah you
know what they
all like well it was so funny it was
such vitriol when this thing was
announced
the next 12 minute old i want to see if
they they they didn't even mention it in
the 12.
they threw vlog in our face like here
bob [ __ ] remember this remember you love
this
it's great you don't make us forget and
and and the only thing i shout out to
dylan i think he did we said look you
know
this thing was well in advance we we
heard you
you know we'll take a look you know that
was the extent of it a tweet
prior to the 12 and then they moved us
on so again
bungie on their own this leads me to
believe
that the financial people have took a
stand and said damn it
this is staying in according to this
budget
[Music]
i'm a firm believer man what are you
thinking man yeah well i i think one of
the
the bad parts was not only the initial
reception of it you know when it was
announced because that was really when
you saw the the buzz
but then when it became delight that it
was not only i mean i guess it was
originally two you knew you were limited
per season
but also you're limited what is it every
two minutes one of these things drops
so this was almost like back to the
curse of osiris the xp grind right
that's
when people discovered that it was the
same thing it was like how did you not
learn that and
how was there yes it wasn't the
developer's decision
to do this it was obviously financial
people but like how did somebody not
bring that up and say like don't you
remember what happened
then how many players we lost but you
know i guess maybe back then the
the content wasn't as good maybe in
cursive osiris where now
you know you have all the glass coming
back you have you know all these
different things that you can do these
weekly missions and that that it is
going to be
there is content there for you to jump
in so at least you can say hey we see
that
we're looking at it go check out all
this other content that you're going to
know and love and go look at the world's
race the world's first race go look at
this
it's great go squirrel like you said
i see them eventually at some point yeah
backing down they always do i mean
bungie that's the thing man
for what it's worth they always listen
to the community and
the destiny community is about the most
predictable gaming community of all like
it's always
the hype and then the content comes out
and then it drops and everybody hates
and then the hype again it's just it's
just constant back and forth i mean it's
it's crazy man but this is the way it is
i guess i i agree
i think you're absolutely right it's
it's a funny it's a fun journey
that you have to not deal with
consistently and talk about the same
thing over and over and over dude that's
what i always told people was like
guardian radio and i mean even you guys
doing your show
destiny is like the golden goose that
just keeps on giving
baby it is the greatest game to podcast
about because
there's always something to talk about
whether it's controversy or whatever
there is
always something in this community
that's just right it's like i don't even
think like you can go search like
world of warcraft podcasts and there's
maybe four or five
search destiny there's probably 40. like
it's just crazy man there's so many
because there's always something and so
everybody in this community is so
passionate and that's a great thing
it really is it's awesome yeah the
passion is always off the charts but
then it turns around and it's like
depending on which direction that
happens which connection is it going
it's gonna be
potentially pretty fire you're in spicy
so that's always the other fun side of
it yeah
so before we get into vog
because that's not quite here that we'll
be launching tomorrow
i wanted to get your take on another
spicy topic in the world of the game
right now
and it's the side that doesn't get a lot
of love at the moment
and that's crucible so from an
outsider's perspective
and you kind of jump in occasionally and
you play don't that often
what does the world of crucible look
like to you from the outside from the
twitter feeds when you jump in
how is that just as something when you
log in what is that world like to you
well somebody
i think would have been you about to
said it earlier when you were talking
about them creating an mmo
and you said that you know they might
say oh we're not going to put our focus
on pvp
i almost jumped in and said like haven't
they already done that like there seems
to be
no focus at all on pvp it says an
outsider looking in and seeing the pvp
community
just kind of shambles like when's the
last time there's been a new map
two years talked to him two years two
years it was because you had
oh my god like what is going on with
that like that is
to me that's that's mind-blowing and
especially because that was like one of
the selling points of the game going
free to play
pvp was free for everybody so why
wouldn't you want people jumping in
i mean look what they're gonna do with
halo infinite obviously bungie is 343.
pvp is free because they they look at
games like cs go
like you know valorent uh any of these
multiplayer games
that's where your community can start
and then you can transition them over so
to me
the fact that there's no new maps in
there to appease that community
is just i don't know what they're doing
over there that that's me is just crazy
um but as somebody who at one point
enjoyed crucible for me
dude i don't even touch the crucible
anymore man especially having not played
it you know keeping up with the game
whenever i go in
i try to go in one point at an iron
banner and just even try to do just
uh you know a regular match i don't have
the weapons anymore you know because i'm
constantly going through that
leveling grind every time i log in i'm
just swapping to the most powerful
weapon that i have
and it's never anything that's going to
crucible which again you know you can
always switch back because if you're not
as long as you're not an iron banner the
weapons don't matter but i just i don't
have
the the meta weapons right now so it's
always like i'm always at a disadvantage
and that's kind of led me to go back to
where i originally started as a bungee
fan with halo halo
you know the original you know halo ce
halo combat evolved
i got a series x here you know luckily i
was able to get one at launch
and have been playing the hell out of
the master chief collection
i've rediscovered my love for the halo
multiplayer again
and you know i i was trying to put my
finger on what it is about that game and
i we've
i remember talking about it on guardian
radio and i've talked about it even on
other podcasts that i've been on talking
about destiny
and i know this is a somewhat again
another hot spicy take
for some people with that play destiny
but
i believe that halo still to this day is
still
played because the way that game was
built was
you had set loadouts you had power
weapons on the map
and the game all came and you had a
little bit of a higher time to kill and
it all came down to
truly map knowledge yes knowing where
those power weapons were
knowing what those timers are and then
it comes down to the skill of knowing
these are the tools that i have at me
right now right you know ibantas you may
shoot me first
but i can still outplay you because i
know the map
i know where i am in the map i know the
tools that i have and multiple times
going back to play that game
i can outplay people sometimes where
destiny is to the point now where i
don't feel like i can do that anymore
and
you know i don't know if that's really
just uh that i'm not in the meta or if
it's because they add in the
the idea of the class abilities which
are super fun getting supers and all
that
but like it had me thinking like and
i've said this before why don't they
create a game mode where it's
here's the crucible lord shaq says all
right guardians you know take off your
armor
every guardian wears the same suit of
armor and maybe every week have set
weapons that you start with but you can
make it lore friendly where it's like
these
these are the weapons this week and then
you have sure you can build your super
throughout a match
but then there's like a power weapon in
halo
there's a super drop that drops in the
middle so teams start fighting over this
part of the map because they know the
super
the instant super drops at this time
frame and everybody's fighting over
there for it it's just
i don't know there's something about
playing halo that to me seems so much
more competitive
and so much more i mean fair is not the
right word but it's like right
just skill based i guess we're
destinations like if i don't have the
meta
you know i know yeah the idea of them
wanting it to be your guardian across
all all play of destiny and i get that
like that's super cool and that that's
fun
but as somebody trying to come back to
it now and then i can even imagine
somebody that's new
to destiny trying to get into it sure
throwing supers around is fun
but getting hit by supers and shot by
you know a hand cannon from halfway
across the map that you don't have that
you will never have
you're just gonna quit you know because
it's like screw this i'm out and you're
gonna go play call of duty or whatever
you know which
i don't know that's kind of where my
take is and then but whenever i say that
people always say like
well we had something like that when
destiny 2 launched and the you know pvp
community hated it because they
wasn't that like the stuff like that
yeah like people were all like it was
all primaries and
it killed the meta but it was like so
what was different about
that time of destiny 2 and let's say a
halo 3.
like what is it about that that was
different and the only thing i can put
my finger on was it was the time to kill
was a little bit longer in halo
and then you had power weapons on the
map and then i
i don't know you know i don't know
really what else it was but there's
something about halo to
me that now is so much more fun than
going to play destiny and like if i had
the choice
it's like halo all day man and that's
why like halo infinite i am super stoked
for
to go play that what i get it no i mean
it makes sense for you because um
you know being that those guys the
originators and like you said it's about
map control
it's people it's it's it's balance you
know it's it's separated
you know because one of the indictments
you said it perfectly you've gone away
you come back now to play pvp but you
don't have the meta weapon so
you don't really stand a fighting chance
unless you've been consistently
involved with the meta and knowing
what's going on and then gotta attain it
before you can even jump in there so
yeah it's an interesting thing
i mean but this back to your overall
point you know again
i've never seen such neglect like this
and the the issue to me like and i said
that noise and other other pockets just
that
again if if resources are issued or
that's fine
but the fact that they're not
communicating it
that is a little troubling to me yeah
man because it is
it is beyond the butt of every joke it
is
it's really bad and this was a you know
i remember correct me for bro
mark did you guys used to have like the
crucible guys and devs on and stuff like
that back yeah man
yeah yeah like definitely in those guys
totally yeah i remember listening to
those episodes and you would get these
very in-depth discussions about the
matter and
the decision-making behind things and
that that doesn't even exist anymore
like those type of deep dives and
conversation like remember we'd be like
hey it's john from the crucible team
here and
you know like you don't even hear from
them i mean dude
i'm i'm still good friends with swain
from crucible radio yeah which
doesn't exist anymore how could it even
even if those guys had kept going how
could it possibly exist today exactly
there's no way like i mean i'm sure if
you want to just keep talking about the
same thing every week but there's
nothing there's no way to talk about the
crucible it's crazy
like shout out mercury's fallout 4 um
you know i'm saying those guys keeping
the touch going because i mean they're
really good
especially with the with the in-depth
aspects the intricacies but
it it it's just one of those things
where it's like
what is going on why are you not talking
to at least give us an
expectation as to when you may address
it and then we to talk
e about the elephant in the room which
is again this supposed
new ip that baby pvp
focus are all the resources there like
what's happening but it's their duty
to communicate i mean new seasons come
out
and we don't have a map to match the you
know what i'm saying
one map that one do you not have one map
a season
one map with europa that planet is
begging to get played on
begging to be played on a snow map i
mean come on you can even put on
a white shader which i don't even know
if we're gonna get tomorrow
um all of that stuff's a thing but no
like one thing that you said mark two
and like
over way too many episodes and probably
yours as well i feel like the idea of
that mode where set loadouts and kind of
like you can pick your options where
it's perfectly balanced like gears
pretty standardized you just got like
set specs
would give people especially you said
like you or a new player a chance to
jump in and
kind of understand pvp
without having crazy ability spam people
have a hundred like intellect specs so
they instantly get their super and they
get it back again
and then they've got this hand cannon as
you said with 5000 ring and i know it's
a joke but
all of these things that people have
grinded for and a new person comes in is
like holy
bee and they can't and they can't get on
board with this and they're like this is
way too big of a hill to climb how much
time do i have to put in to get
reasonable at this and it's like there's
a lot of work that you got to put in a
lot of different guns that you got to go
get and then the skill sealing and
movement everything else to learn
but there's no like leveled playing
field and one thing it's like shout out
to division trust me it has its ups and
downs
but one of the modes and actually i
heard it was actually kind of working on
coming back is survival and that's
this weird thing about a battle royale
that does have and i guess it's probably
that ease of access for a lot of people
you can hop in and know nothing but you
know everybody else is at least
starting at the same point every round
yeah so like
whether they pick up a cool gun like hey
they got it that match but if we start
the next round we're all flying in
empty-handed
and it's like i'm not a huge fan of
battle royals but there is something
about that of at least i know
everybody starts the same somebody could
be better than me totally know where to
go
better at those quick gun plays in like
the high tent settings that's fine
but if i step into a match and i just
know i'm behind
from the from the get-go that's tough
and i
i do like i like what you said people
haven't played in a while play every so
often
if there was a mode to just be like i
want to play some standardized destiny
pvp and it's like they
they won't do that and i think that
whole standard like certain like you
know a couple pulse rifles hand cannons
scouts a couple primaries where you can
pick from you got a shotgun a fusion
like one of each basic weapon
you can pick and they're they're going
to balance that one mode to be as
perfect as possible and it's like
you could have like pure skill in there
you could lower the ability times you
could mess with stuff
they have crucible as well which are
crucible keep keep crucible keep that if
people want that but like
give this other playlist and you know i
just i don't know man
it's one of those weird things and the
other thing to think about too is you
know i know
with some conversations i've had with
not only bungie developers but other
people in the industry i mean
i mean it's obvious right now the best
advertising for a game is twitch
or yes or live youtube people love just
watching people play video games
go back to sure we would have the big
raids come out and everybody's you know
checking out you know goth and broman
back in the day you know and all that
for the pve stuff but they weren't going
to them for pvp what kept destiny
at the top of that for the longest time
was your true vanguard all these guys
playing pvp all of that and now
sure some of them are still dabbling in
it but it's just it's not like it used
to be and i think if you
were at least putting out new maps you'd
at least have people going in there and
then
but like a standardized playlist really
then levels it up to
it's all about that skill and yes i mean
any of the bigger games right now on
twitch a lot of them are you know i mean
a lot of them are battle royales of
course but it's
it's this pvp you know people want to
watch pvp and right now
your game is out there as a free-to-play
game so you want to get people playing
your game and you're
not putting out new pvp content like
what are you doing
like you're just you're right there
you're automatically just totally just
not like just i guess uh what do you
want to say just avoiding a whole new
potential audience that could be there
for you and it's it to me it's
that's just crazy i don't understand it
completely agree
baffling no that one's a little on the
mind-boggling side of
course but we do have some things going
on
in the pvp world shockingly because we
always do
and this is gonna feel like year one of
your podcasts was we're talking about
the vaulted glass again
so we've got the first reissued raid
we're actually going to need to use that
little legends tat little button
on the director and we got to go back
into the vault of glass tomorrow
and for obviously my co-host this is a
special piece because when it comes to
raid rankings
it sits at the top above everything else
for this man
pretty much no matter what i don't think
i've seen anything knock it off its
pedestal yet
so i gotta start with you and then we'll
get to mark but as this is your
this is your baby how how are you
feeling going
and we're 24 hours 26 hours away at this
point
how are you doing are you are you
jumping out of your skin
you got your team ready you got your
like food and everything
for the long haul where are we yeah
where are we at little man it's we we're
on the eve of greatness man i mean this
is this is special for me i mean
you you know the story you know it's one
of those things you know vlog
literally prevented me from doing
destiny of the track
literally because i i was very jaded i
was very you know
concerned about the game i didn't
understand you know what the mmo and the
console space was so
you know when people were telling me
about oh no you gotta get to level 30.
you got to get you gotta do the raid and
i'm like ah i already beat the campaign
but you know i remember again just
starting the spire and opening that bad
boy
up and and going in there and the
jumping puzzle and just the mystery of
it all and then
obviously to um to the atheon fight the
oracles all the different encounters
and saying okay again i wasn't a wild
guy like i i never
experienced anything on that level
cooperatively in a video game
six players no help you don't know
what's going on
so yeah for this is special you know um
i'm very
excited because there are a lot of my
team that came in at destiny 2
and never had that luxury of really
doing vog
you know and for me there's that
curiousness okay
what do they change what yeah man do i
expect like a major major change
probably not but i'm
curious to see what nuance is how it
translates next gen
and then this is a unique world first
because it's like everyone's 1300 so
it's
full accessibility from the jump
everyone can jump in
right and then you throw okay
the world's first this means beating it
but then beating it
into special challenge mode where you
don't know and it's an automatic
election it's a whole new dynamic
i'm excited i'm excited we've got to see
what's going on and then of course
the weapons come on
the class fadebringer you know again
one of the reasons why it ranks so high
because
my ra my raid rankings are very
complicated
the reason why yes nostalgia yes
i'll be the first to admit he will
always give me crap and people give me
crap
you know you're prisoner at the moment
king falls better and i always tell
people
one a one b one c however you want to
rank it but the reason
being is that again and i've always and
again not to attack kings folks
kings falls that's amazing but my main
reason is i
always feel rewards don't get valued and
enough in my
ranking system for raids right and
and vaulted glass boy you know what i'm
saying like yeah
it's good demonic weapons in this thing
and i'm dying to see how they translate
so look
you know it's gonna be fun man i'm
excited it's on a saturday thank god i
gotta get everybody in
and i'm ready man i'm ready i'm hyped i
even hit you up i was like bro if you
ain't got nobody
i'll get the crew we're gonna go over
there i think i got it basically i think
i gotta go because i gotta know what i'm
saying i'm actually gonna bring my
brother in
so i'm gonna bring stonewall yep got a
couple other people so we got just a
kind of a mixed crew
because i don't have any of my original
players that i played with even probably
still touch in the game
so but no for me it's like it is one of
those it's on a saturday
it's yeah it's gonna be weird because
it's a new raid in destiny 2 it's going
to look it's going to look amazing on pc
i'm waiting for that because
like you take this thing you know high
resolution high frame rate however
you know fancy you can play next gen
consoles field of view for everybody is
going to be a little different animal
all that stuff is going to look really
cool
but it's also going to be very strange
to be like it's a new raid but i feel
like i already know most of the
encounters and what to do there's going
to be
tweaks and there might be wyvern
champions totally yeah i know that stuff
i was like i'll get to those like
speculations of what you guys think
but it's also the first time very
weirdly to go into a raid and
you know kind of you know have most of
it in your head already going in because
we've experienced well there's also half
the people who probably haven't touched
it ever seen it no idea what that was
coming
so i will be curious also when we get
done
say next week to know with the knowledge
that we've got
and then also experiencing something
like last wish which is just
insanely complicated you know 18 hours
was the first clear
the depth of the mechanics in the last
wish versus
you know vlog it was not as complicated
as some of the stuff they have made now
so i'm very curious
how they balance adding a little with
but you know still giving it the proper
treatment to still be vog so i'm very
curious and i wanted to ask you guys
what changes do you want to see what do
you think would be just crazy
where do you see changes come in and
then just you know mark as well where
were you sitting at us uh you know
seven years ago and now we're back in
time so one one change that i i hope is
there
and if it's not i think it's a complete
miss what what number
chest was the one that everybody still
has been looking for is it like the
seventh or eighth chapter six or seven
chests yeah yeah like there's a seventh
chest in the vault of glass if there is
not an extra chest in this vault
in this vault they failed right there
failure
absolute failure it's got to be there
right they have luke smith
you better be hiding that chest in this
in this rage because if not
uh yeah you're crazy but just real quick
before we talk about this dude
like this to me vaulted glass like
a lot of it is the nostalgia of it and
the unknown and a little insider
baseball for guardian radio and i'm not
going to go
i'm not going to say who it was or
anything but
um and it wasn't me i'll tell you how
much it wasn't me but we knew that there
was a a very tight clan
pre-destiny one coming out that went to
bungie
did a play test of a raid and this was a
team that played a lot of halo they
played a lot of battlefield
and afterwards these guys could not
complete it and so for me
like i had heard about raids and
obviously world of warcraft like i said
i never really got into raiding and all
that
so for me this was really my first thing
i'm like how can i be playing like a
shooter game not
be able to complete it like i didn't it
wasn't comprehending to me that
you have these mechanics where everybody
had to do their own part
and then of course you know vaulted
glass comes out and i actually didn't
run it blind i had a
um some a group of guys that you know a
couple listeners in that and then some
of us on the original guardian radio
ran through it but that experience still
to this day
is one of the just most incredible
experiences when they're like okay you
need to go stand over here
and then you may go through this portal
and if you go through this portal you
gotta look up but you gotta keep moving
because your screen's gonna go black if
your screen goes black we're all dead
and i'm just like what are you talking
about and then you know you start doing
it and you start getting it and it's
like all right well when you come back
out we all gotta run
to the center piece and you know shoot
at this guy and i mean the completion of
that was just
awesome and having the jumping puzzle
and just the the aesthetic
of the aesthetic of the raid is just
awesome and even just the
the idea of opening it was awesome now
we do know with this right i mean
we're going to have to open it but it's
not going to be obviously in a public
space because
we're not going to be but just that's
going to be i think a lot of fun which i
have a feeling
there's going to be it's going to be
difficult to open the vault i think a
lot of people are kind of
just thinking oh we're going to be able
to get in and just do it like we used to
you're talking about champions getting
thrown down
how long is it going to take for the
first team to open that vault i
guarantee you it's going to take a
little while there's going to be
something new to crack this thing open
the vex are not just going to put this
thing out
and have it be like it used to be you
know that this isn't going to be the
same you think it is
but it's not they're definitely going to
um you know make it a little bit
different but
shout out to the man who probably knows
what the vex is doing shout out to bife
but actually i wanted to say this
morning uh he wanted to say hi to you
directly because i tweeted out the
thumbnail this morning
and it was wrong thank you all of you
who nobody noticed it by the way
because it's a season of the chosen and
he's like by the way i'm just in like
detail mode and i caught this one thing
by the way shout out say hi to mark for
me so bye says hi by the way
thank you all of you who no one caught
the thumbnail it's been fixed now
but yeah i wanted to say like if you
want to know what the [ __ ] is doing he's
the one you want to go he's all about
the lore videos this season he's got
tons of stuff to talk about so sorry
back to you i just had to
tell you that from him i you know i
talked about being kind of always behind
in the story like
biff's videos are the way i catch up on
the story still
i've been doing it since you know the
very beginning and still to this day
it's biff you know go
go see what what video he put out about
the lore and i'll be able to catch up
um do we know because the first run i
did in vault i got vision of confluence
okay which was my scout rifle through
basically all of destiny one i would
always have this thing equipped kind of
leveled it up as much as i could until
you know we couldn't do it anymore
is that going to be a drop and i believe
it
is from what i believe because i hear a
lot of people talking fake
bringer they're talking vex yeah if you
even want to go
into spoiler-ish stuff you can look at
the vault of glass gear there's a bunch
of mods that have
leaked out but if you guys don't want to
hear it fair warning
i'm just going to list them off real
fast so you guys know
we've got five four three two one you've
been warned spoiler
fade bringer can cannon pray death
revenge
sniper vision of confluence scout
pound verdict shotgun corrective measure
machine gun
he's in vengeance rocket launcher and i
believe that's all of them and then they
have a
time lost version as well and of course
vex yes those are the ones that we're
aware of
and now right now though and i mean i
don't want to go back to pvp but like
scout rifles are pretty weak in the game
right now right is that kind of so it's
like i'm like i would love to go play
buddy
i would love to play and get the vision
of confluence but it's like if it's not
gonna you know do me any good what's the
point right
like why it's not i don't know there's
actually
a big uproar right now with hungary
that's i wanted to bring that up and be
like
i just got it and i'm like scouts are
just not in a good place
that's all i rolled in destiny one man
hung jury was
ironic and it's just like i looked at it
i
i
looked at what the rpm was i was like oh
definitely not
well i was like yeah it's just it's just
even with the the roles are good they
have great perk combinations
but you know it's just bungie is
insistent that
they don't want to reward scout play
that long distance
you know safe kind of play style
and scouts continue to suffer they've
made they've actually said it they've
actually made a conscious decision
because even with the last update
the only thing they did to them was the
uh the aim assist yeah
yeah so what yeah what don't they want
people is that in pvp they don't want
people doing that
i mean either like it's the same thing i
feel like why snipers are not in the
place they used to be as well
they don't want to sit back and shoot
from a safe space yeah they hate that
and that's like that was destiny one
dude with my vision and then you have
your icebreaker and you're like pop-pop
with the icebreaker switch over
but the game here so much fun man like
that was it dude that was
it i'm with you bro and what it is is
they're trying to
force this play style with and get the
other weapons
up the part i mean in their defense i
would say the other archetypes have come
up as a whole
and it's probably the most balanced it's
been from a man as far as
weapon archetypes you could use and
actually be competitive
except scout scout because scout yeah
they just like it it sucks you know
they they they're anti sitting up wells
just melt something from a distance
you know kind of thing sit in a bubble
kind of and and that's the part that's
that's troubling because
we know how iconic these weapons are
hung jury you know i'm saying vision
you know we know it and it's just like
man
it just doesn't feel good to see them as
an average
weapon yeah i mean like sadly one more
time what's gonna be the highly sought
after gun
a hand cannon cause i swear whoever
makes the sandbox
loves hand cannons and nothing else
because fatebringer is the one
what is the meta in pvp like those are
the way that some hannans can like
compete with like
pulse rifles even for example still
astoundingly the range that hand cannons
have like
120s to a point i'm just like how are
you how okay this doesn't i'm fine
okay yeah it's like anything that says
rifle versus what looks like a giant ass
revolver
sorry language for the first time yeah
it's like somehow those two should not
be the same accuracy at range
in my head at all in my mind sometimes
so
but yeah i was like there are some
iconic weapons but as you guys said it's
like is the nostalgia gonna be fun but
then is the loot gonna be worth it
and then also they're you know toying
with first the challenges which are
gonna be 24 hours and they're going to
bring it back a little later in the
season
and then master difficulty is that where
the time lost come in but again what's
going to be the difference
what makes a vision like okay so i got
the time lost maybe that's like the
master difficulty
for vision if scouts still suck that
still sucks
no i'm like for me it's the collection
of it i guess yeah it's like so you can
look up some of the perk pools on these
things
and they look cool and you've got some
possible awesome combinations
but again certain archetypes still just
dominate other ones so you're going to
be pushed still into a certain direction
so it is
yeah i'm still very curious to see
however the dust settles once this
weekend is done of nostalgia
and you know how they'd make the changes
to the raid do they keep it close but
give us some fun tweaks do champions
make it on fun what is master gonna do
this season to see how they handle
because honestly this is probably gonna
they're probably already working on it
if they're going to but picture king's
fault during which queen
literally literally a year later from
now your six-month like next raid that
they release
that just is screaming king's fall as a
throwback because that's the number
two if you're gonna bring else anything
back like you know raid that they can
put the fresh coat of paint on
give you more content six months from
the expansion that is the one
before you would ever touch siva because
that breaks other story stuff i'm sure
but
or crota right even before you probably
do people always say that's a dungeon
but i still had fun in it um
i loved it i did too i had fun but yeah
like that was my first blind raid so
to me that the nostalgia of that was
just yeah it was epic man yep
it was fun um but yeah it's like that's
kind of where i am very curious where
the dust settles after this weekend
because
you know you get to log into venus i'm
going to turn around and look at that
blue lava volcano in the sandbox and be
like
this is awesome you're going to have
your invisible walls be like okay i'm
stuck here
and then you're funneled in and as you
said is the opening going to be hard or
is this thing going to get knocked out
in like two hours
i'm so curious to see how this goes
because i wish yeah
good mark oh i said real quick have they
said is volatile glass
leaving next season or is it staying
yeah it's in the game around
yeah now that's the other thing is again
you know i kind of just look at the
destiny community from afar now
so deep stone [ __ ] i might say it
doesn't matter anymore
it doesn't matter anymore
i see a lot of people kind of upset with
that because it's like hey i paid for
that raid
even though everybody's getting vaulted
glass free that's cool but like i paid
for that raid like i should be
able to run that literally are you guys
feeling about that well i went
i had my two cents last time but basic
for me was
no i went off because you paid for an
expansion while this is a free raid it's
an old raid if you
paid for b somebody could sit there and
pay for beyond light today and it's not
considered
a pinnacle and they may not have had the
expansion yet but they're new cool
here's beyond light here's a raid
well there's some weapons in there but
it's not going to help you level up
anymore but this is a raid this is like
really tough stuff
it's really the current raid right it's
the current expansion rate it's the
story rate this and they and i knew also
my
curiosity changed when there's like on
the legends tab i was like oh they're
just sit putting vault of glass in a
little
you know isolated little bucket that's
not actually in the world
it's just an old raid experience and i'm
like so you're literally putting it in
there and you still turn off the
pinnacles
it's 10 levels of pinnacles and you
already did the
contest mode for vault it wouldn't
matter if people were 13 10 or 13 20
going in
1300 as high is gonna matter tomorrow so
it didn't matter at all and they took it
away and then they took the value out of
the biggest piece of the year which is
the paid expansion no that right that
irked me a lot and i saw other people
saying it too that
no that was but also i mean the weirdest
thing is the raid
lost its pinnacle status but like the
10-minute exo simulation
mission or the empire hunts that are
still tied to that expansion
those are pinnacles those are pinnacles
which are emotional
and then your entire crypt crazy raid
that's awesome with like eight tracks
and everything that broke people oh no
that one's not i'm like
i don't understand that that's a great
rate that's crazy man and they clarified
multiple times that
yeah it's intentionally not pinnacle i
was like okay you're just
yep they embraced it so no i was not a
fan at all i couldn't stand that one
yeah
yeah that doesn't make sense to me at
all man yeah they're trying to it's
forced engagement they they're trying to
push everyone
into vault and and i get it and to me
it's like vault didn't even
vault is going to stand on its own
regardless
and like you said mark this is paid
content this is the expansion
like i i did not like that decision at
all you know and we we've all been
beating the drum
how come at least at the very minimum
there's not a raid
pinnacle rotation serious weekly list
like
you know this week hey if you jump in
this you're going to get a pinnacle you
know
last week just you know next week or
whatever at least do that because we do
recognize this is premium content and
it's being neglected
and again they're forcing this into
vault which is nice but
you can't do that to deep stone you
can't that's a great
raid that is that is a really strong
raid so yeah it's disappointing it's
very disappointing the way they hear
that might be i mean as you said the
rotating pinnacles for both dungeons
and raids feel like it's really got to
be thing by the time which queen comes
out if they don't do that and they just
keep rotating through
there's just a lot of amazing things
that there's no incentive to run so
unless i'm just like
hey a whole bunch of people that i play
with you guys want to drag this person
through a cool raid
it's fun every so often but like do i
get anything from it as somebody who
plays they did the spoils as this like
you know small edition but outside of
that
and they even took most of the spoils
out of deep stone crypt i'm like yeah
like what is going on like why
remove the incentive to run it like i
don't
you guys know has there been any data
and i don't even know how you would
really find this because i remember like
with guardian radio to see
raid completions we would always look at
trophies and things like that right but
is there and have there been any numbers
and i don't think they would ever
release this
of how many people got or played beyond
light with game pass
that's a good point because technically
it's free then right yeah so i mean deep
zone [ __ ] if it was a lot of game pass
people it's free now it wasn't free on
pc right because
destiny is not game pass yet right um
and maybe that was kind of their mindset
was like a lot of people just kind of on
this platform played it for free so
screw it we'll just kind of
put it off to the side but but again
then they're giving you vaulted glass
for free so it's like well then
you know if you're going to kind of put
these out there but um
yeah it just didn't seem to be necessary
to take one nope
to take it away for especially when they
lowered the 10 down it was like we
the whole power the leveling thing is a
like that's a podcast in itself
but yeah like now we're down to ten
power levels it's just the pinnacle if
you were caught up so then you have the
shorter grind but then they just felt
like
lengthening your grind again by taking
those pinnacles away is all they were
doing
now you're two weeks later and being
able to you know push for 1320 because
right now
you're not like without the raid
especially with all those plus twos
you're not going to be like
13 20. most people there are a few i'm
sure
but most are not going to be there so
it's it's very very strange agreed
mistake there uh
but we do have a little bit of news
obviously so you guys said 1300 is going
to be the power cap
period that's contest mode so from
saturday when it launches which is 10
a.m
pacific time it's going to go live your
contest mode is going to be active so as
long as you're 1300
you don't need to be any higher and that
is the highest you'll be able to be for
basically any encounter
um but then they have challenge mode so
you're going to go through as a fire
team
beat it once and then if you're going
for the belt which is a silver belt
instead of a gold because it is a
reissued raid they didn't make that
distinction
um you're gonna have challenge modes and
i wondered if you guys wanted to go
through the encounters
how you guys think each of the
encounters because the main four
obviously you said the entrance you've
got the oracle whole
fight and you know taking them all out
then you've got
i guess there's five because then you've
got what's that and then they start
yeah yeah cause don't you fight the
oracles and then they start kind of
coming up from the bottom too right
after that and then you've got the boss
there which i can never remember his
name templar
templar yep you got the gatekeeper and
atheon so there's five
possible places so i wanted to kind of
go through and see what you guys think
for a challenge mode from what you
remember how they can make that a bit
spicier
for the challenge mode so start with the
entrance
what do you guys think because that's
the three pillars on the outside yeah
gotta stand on them to build them
and you gotta keep people off of them
long enough to make them built so
outside of that mechanic itself yeah
what do you see i think mark you alluded
to something that i think
could happen i think that could get
crazy like they could throw champions
unstoppables or something in this marvel
like to really ramp up the intensity of
having to
because let's be right standing on
plates you know so right yeah
what do you do like and i think yeah
like you really intensify you really
throw the kitchen sink out there and
there's not going to be other players in
there so you can maybe ramp up
you know play account maybe not
battlegrounds level but
get intense but what do you think you
think that you know they could do that
or add something else into it
what you feel what what was the right i
can't believe i can't think of the name
it was the right i mean it was a
the launch rate with d2 with uh um
levison levithan leviathan and there was
the one part we had to get the big keys
and kind of slam them down yeah yeah
yeah
what if there's some sort of things like
that where it's not just standing on the
plate like you have to go
kill somebody off in a corner grab that
bring that back to the plate and in the
meantime
there's somebody who can come on the
plate and basically make that because
remember that
they just kept coming at you and then if
eventually that key could disappear if
enough guys
on the plate i could see them doing
something like that but
later in you're managing three plates at
once you know it's not just so you're
basically having two people where one's
having to run and grab it bring it back
and it's on the complete opposite side
even almost how um
the silva raid you know how kind of you
were always having to get empowered and
like you'd be empowered on one side but
have to quickly run to the other
it could be something like that where
you have to run to the other side
grab whatever and quickly get back or
else that thing may expire there's a
timer on it i could see them doing
something like that
rather than just stand on plates fight
waves of enemies
you know that might be a cool way to
kind of just add this neat little uh
stress factor to it just make it a
little bit more difficult i actually
like that
yeah to give you a little more activity
to do because if it's just defense and
you're like
here's some champions i think that would
definitely be a missed opportunity said
if there's more activity
and to make it even longer you could
stand on the plates but then it's like
okay so
and it may be the rotation of the five
maybe it's one key as you said at a time
and you kind of have to like shift the
coverage because one person's gotta run
and go get it
and then you could have to hit all three
so like the shift to give the help where
you know the isolated person's kind of
on their own still taking a bit of a
beating that would be
i like that that's actually a really
cool idea it's actually pretty cool see
that hire me bungie come on yeah
there we go yep got the design uh
part two so now we get down um obviously
you know they're going to kick you off
the ledge up top that's going to be just
you know spawning with your allies
but oracles so normal mode obviously we
had her like three four five six i
forget how many waves like how you went
through them
and just kind of defending the confluxes
where do you guys see
changes here between guys
locations weird oracle locations where
do you think they're going to change the
curve ball on the oracle
run i think sniper locations will be
different if there's a way
to do that because remember you're
always having to pick up those snipers
up top like one person
i got snipers like you just had to
always be you know on top of that i
could see them moving somehow or maybe
some pieces in there some of those
that's the one thing i'm interested like
a lot of the pillars in that that we
know
are they going to be in different places
and i think that's one way they could
actually
it's the same space but just you know
your jumps aren't going to be the same
which
i mean i'm going to talk about the
jumping puzzle as well which i have a
feeling is going to be completely
different than what it was before
and you're not going to be able to
cheese it by just floating across you
know and then jumping
um it's going to be a jumping puzzle
this time france i'm telling you that
right now
that's the only time i like a lot blue
did you but uh but i could see them
doing that putting you know different
architecture kind of in the room so then
they're kind of hiding snipers and
things like that up top
um and just make it a little bit more
difficult i think
one thing i hope they don't do i i hope
they don't do anything with with
sequence a specific sequence of of order
of doing stuff when it comes to
challenges and stuff like that that'll
be brutal
but um yeah i don't know i'm just i'm
just wait i'm waiting for the sound cues
i i for some reason i don't know why i
like the sound cues
in that joke oh yeah i don't know why i
just i love it i love it always
it's nostalgic for me um yeah we we got
to see i
i i'm very curious about that one
because i'm like what can you
do and you make some good points as far
as like changing things up positioning
but what can you really add to that make
like
mechanic i don't know i'm very curious
because i think
that has probably the some of the more
potential besides
we'll get to atheon to really add
new mechanics to to add a little flavor
to just stand there and just shoot so
we'll see what about you what are you
thinking yeah because that's the hard
thing is because a lot of it is like
everybody got to hold down their door
but i mean we didn't have the abilities
we do now like a wave grenade and things
where you can just
wipe groups of enemies not just like you
could throw a grenade every so often
people go heavy into discipline have
their grenades up every so often be
sitting in the sun well
just absolutely you know covering areas
in
you know defense and all the stuff
coming out it's just going to die so
then you're as you said the snipers
i unfortunately i'm gonna probably call
champion hobgoblins that i'm gonna
absolutely hate with a loving passion
i know it's gonna take some champions
and right now unfortunately that's
definitely gonna be a scout rifle for
barriers so those are gonna be
champions for sure facts um
they haven't yet to do a wyvern champion
and if they don't put this in vog
somewhere i was like yeah this is this
is the opportunity for them to make it
wyvern champion
i was like and i think this has got to
be the one so
that would definitely throw a wrench
into that entire encounter
um they could throw it in other places
but i think this would be the one where
they'd be like oh this is gonna be weird
i think that would be the perfect place
maybe one like one per conflux or
something like that to just go okay this
is big
like that i think would be cool a mess
don't get me wrong
but yeah i think that would throw a
wrench into things enough by
as you said you still have the oracles
you got the confluxes you got to defend
without moving too much and the
architecture changes which will still
probably be there hopefully at least
um they do i think some as you said
they're already gonna have the shield
so you're gonna have that mechanic when
it comes to the templar those pieces
will be there i think for that oracle
conflux fight i think yeah i think it's
probably going to be champion mess
that's my guess on that one i
i don't know of a whole lot else i can
think of overload minotaurs rushing the
complexes
yeah that's probable teleport teleport
i'm here look hi
oh crazy
so after that one hold on what's the
order
get the bees right is it the gorgon maze
yeah and then the jumps right
yeah so gore guns do you guys think it's
just gonna be a different order
or do you think they're even gorgons you
know what there's not
there isn't uh i guess it's not vex
technology but what's the stuff they use
it was a lot you came across it in
shadow keep a lot where it was like the
uh
the little like i call them trip mines
but the things that would freeze you in
place
oh the fallen the fallen ones and
whatever it's like a circle and you kind
of step it in
like
yeah so like yeah whole team is like
running and you quickly turn the corner
and you're frozen and it's like all
right shoot it like get out of it
because it's like locking you down i can
see them hiding something like that
around there so it's like
you're trying to get through and it's
completely just stopping your team in
place and then of course you're gonna
wipe
um i hope they still have because there
was a that chest that was there too
remember you could always kind of go off
to the side and get that chest
always had to go get that and kind of
come back and then go back through it i
hope that chest is still there
um but i can see them yeah just again
maybe the architecture changing it's not
gonna be the same maze route um so
people are going to have to relearn
the the way the maze is and um
you know maybe those gorgons move a
little bit faster this time so you're
going to
have to about that yep rather than just
have them kind of be the slower maybe
even have their
vision cone a little bit wider maybe
just to make a little bit more difficult
but there's going to be a lot of wipes
in there
so i think i'm pretty confident
that is going to be an aggressive
hunting type situation because i feel
like
in d2 especially with um
zero hour like they've gotten into a fun
little bag with things
chasing you and hunting you down and
creating terror
like creating true fear like oh it's
coming hurry up
like thinking about what you're saying
if they have some evil lockdown
mechanics to avoid so that you don't get
stuck in place and
the girl guys sees you i definitely
think
they're gonna have fun with that one
that one i i am
very curious if they get ambitious with
it with truly giving you fear
when that and that gaze come they could
do something kind of crazy because you
said zero had made me think of something
because as you go through zero hour
where trevor is at specifically that
idea you have the four switches you got
to hit open the door
what if when it comes to vex not
switches you got to get a couple people
to stand on plates
like you got to get a couple of people
who know to stand on plates
get like this unlocking tone then you
guys can go for
like the final door run like you have to
like unlock the shield wall or something
like that by getting to a couple
different locations
oh no that that one they have a lot of
potential in there just to
complete you know throw chaos in and see
what absolutely happens which i cannot
wait to see what they do
that's when i think as you said there's
a lot of potential for them to get
really aggressive
or make something that nobody sees
coming so i hope that one for sure
is going to be mixed up the gore guns
are kind of special so i hope they're in
there in some aspect whether they're
like
you know old gorgons or some other time
thing related to them but like i hope
they're still there
their sound effect still is terrifying
like wow
yes every time yep but yeah when you get
through that one then we get to
the jumps so you finally pop out and
you're like oh
okay and then there's that other you
know chest that you can run off to after
that one when you fall way
down if you make that jump and hold it
and all that stuff um
but then you have the shortest jumping
puzzle that looks short but then nobody
makes it
yeah you have one guy make it and just
sit there like come on guys like can i
do this like i'm gonna go
cook some burgers i'll be back when you
guys are down but i mean as even as a
titan i mean i was able i remember i'd
always wait it would it would appear and
i could do like i think i would hit the
first platform the second platform maybe
the third then i could jump and go to
the right and i think echo doctor and
said it in the bottom
that you could i would basically just
fall all the way down and kind of just
slow myself down a little bit so i
wouldn't die
and you could land on the platform down
there so i don't think they're gonna let
you do that this time
there's definitely gonna be either that
you know little area where you would
land is just gonna be gone
and walled off or they're just totally
changing the way
you know the platforms spawn in the
location all that
um which is fun man like that's the
thing like i loved even in
i mean we mentioned even um was it crota
or no king's fall had the jumping puzzle
right
yeah the big swings in those platforms
like that stuff is just fun man
it's a lot of fun oh yeah oh yeah yeah i
think they'll have probably some of the
most fun
with daddy carter yep uh so after the
jumping puzzle which we expect to be
different i wonder if they'll use that
little portal down on the bottom that
people you know kind of wonder from the
whisper of the worm
uh mission that everybody joked you
could see vault through there and it's
the one where if you went down in
vault of glass you got to see that one
um so all of those little teases and
easter eggs are there
then we get the gatekeeper and most
people just nuked him from the back
yeah like he was not exactly an
encounter he was just sitting in the
back every sat back there kind of sniped
him from the doorway make sure you get
your shots in
and then it opens up do you think
they're gonna make more out of that or
is he just like
mini boss before you get to the main
event
big mark what's your date well this is
kind of funny you mentioned gatekeeper
and i was like who like i don't even
remember that because that's how fairly
pointless that encounter was it was just
like you just melted them instantly
every time so
um i mean i could see them doing that i
mean why not it just extends the rate a
little bit more
maybe put some sort of mechanic in him i
don't really know what it would be other
than maybe just put more
ads kind of around them um but i could
see them doing that just to add a little
flavor to it because
like i said i mean for many people
probably like me he was just a nothing
like he yeah i
actually forgot about the gatekeeper
because he would just wreck him
immediately
so i could see them and something what
it is i don't know but um
i could see them doing that yeah and
then anything for you cog on him
just kind of see if something happens
you'll be basically surprised he's even
a thing
yeah and then of course the big fight so
all right mr vaulted glass what do you
what do you think because this is one of
the things that you love is splitting
the team i love it
split it in half you got the oracle
fight you gotta have the push
off the ledge right you're gonna push it
right off the ledge and then pull out
your legs
get him to kneel down for crota i still
can't believe that was figured out that
was still insane
oh crazy just crazy guess
what do you think this is the one
they've got to do something iconic you
know um
guardians make their own fate it's
probably one of the more popular destiny
things in the history
of destiny i mean luke smith used it
when they got away from
from activision bro it's popular so
yeah like that i'm expecting maybe i'm
getting myself too hyped
but that's the one i'm expecting all the
stops
that fight is a great encounter and i
i really expect them to
really ramp up intensity really ramp up
you know
go into the different you know locations
of both teams
split up obviously the blur stuff and
stuff but yeah i expect
a fight forming before you go inside and
each uh each each team has to go in um
i'm
curious what i'm almost confident atl's
getting
a damage check like i i've almost
i don't i know people ain't gonna like
it but like
they don't like the melting right so i'm
very curious
if it's gonna be a situation where they
put checks
you know on on his health bar but yeah i
mean i'm expecting something epic there
i
i i can't put my finger on it but just
the sheer scope of it
they gotta do something epic there so i
don't know yeah i'm curious what you
think there what's the big one
echo doctrine said it in the chat and i
remember doing that he said like they
would put three people specifically at
the back of the map and those three were
the ones that would go
and get teleported and then they did
change it to random which i've always
liked that about the raids like even
thinking about king's fall when
you know you would randomly be the
person that had to jump and you're like
oh god like you know i don't want to be
the one that became you like
i like that so i hope i know echo doctor
and i get you man i feel that you hope
they go back to it but i like the
randomness of it because it's just
i don't just kind of add to the fun of
it but i could see them maybe i mean you
mentioned i totally forgot about that
that whisper portal
you have that glimpse what if the the
areas you go to when you're teleport
what if there's like
six different areas that you can
possibly go to
so it's not the standard two you may
teleport to a random place
you know maybe on uh you know europa
maybe there's a europa area or
whatever so when you spawn in you don't
know and then
you're constantly having to race so it's
not just those two you need to memorize
where you're shooting the
they were oracles right you were
shooting you gotta you know figure out
where these new ones are i could see
them doing something like that and then
that just changes it so
you know and then having a bigger
rotation of potential portals
plus then having it randomized people
that have maybe never been on europa
that first time they see it they're like
oh man i don't know where to go and then
everybody wipes and then you do it again
and
that they don't get teleported but
someone else gets teleported to
you know wherever titan let's say
suddenly titan makes a quick little
comeback and it's a little titan jumping
puzzle
i think that would be cool or uh oracle
you know portal i could see them doing
that that would be cool
because that's not a huge space they
need to need to really make and
they could just utilize a long hallway
essentially or you know corridor from an
area from
the previous maps and maybe there's a
way to kind of link that together i
think that would be cool
but that sounds kind of fun yeah i mean
for you so you got the platforms you got
to sit on you know there's probably
going to be champions they'll throw in
there while you defend the platforms
obviously build which location
you go to then you get teleported in
you're like okay which one do we
actually have to keep open and defend
um more locations would be really good
because it is
if it's just one or the other then you
know i guess i would wonder if there
were more locations
how would you know which platform to
hold down
because that was one of the things like
is it true yeah you're right yeah so it
was like i forget i was like and that's
one of those i will i hope they do
something like that but also it's like
for the mechanics which side is it and i
forget what the
people call them you gotta know which
side to stand on to open it back up so
they get through
but even when you're inside whether it's
two six like i'd love to see more
variety believe me
uh i think we always said like past and
future
maybe like one one portal you were kind
of in the past one in the future one was
more green one was more brown
i feel like yeah yeah or yeah green and
brown was one way to do it yeah yeah
um but yeah when you go in it's like how
are they gonna handle the oracles
because when we start
especially on challenge mode we're not
gonna have oracle weapons
those are not even going to be a thing
there yeah you're right so the oracles
are going to be
just slower to kill you're going to have
to put all the damage especially if
you're going in and trying to help
people they don't know what look
i just thought about it you know what
they're going to do they're probably
going to do the mod system
again oh i mean you know they are yeah
they're gonna do the mod system again
you put this bottle on you do a little
bit of extra damage
because now the raid armor has the extra
mod slot now
for for for specific mechanics per
encounter yeah i can basically tell you
those are there
oh shout out to my discord who is on top
of like
stuff new rad shout out to that manager
yeah
so i mean there's oracle disrupter mods
so they will be they will be a thing but
again first time through you may or may
not have those
there's other interesting mods to make
that stuff you know a little more
manageable to kill
but yeah it's like those are those are
gonna be a thing depending on what
weapons you use
i still wish some of those weapons would
be intrinsic though like fake bringer
should just have it on there the way it
used to and
exactly man yep the international the
pieces of weapons are something i still
truly miss to this day yeah yeah i mean
that to me and again let's say that's
something that
chased me away from destiny because it's
not but like i said right now the
current
season pass of having to unlock those
mods it's not as fun man like when you
got those weapons like when you would
get vaping or with that as an intrinsic
thing you were like
yes cause next time i run it next week
i'm gonna you know be able to go with
her and do
do some more damage where instead you
know it's it's not that anymore
um so i kind of wish it was that way too
man that was kind of
some of the fun of the original d1 i
agree
but yeah so i was like you'll see
champions then you know somebody's gonna
pick up the shield bust out do you still
think we're going to do our damage from
our little baby island platform in the
middle that you run to when you can't
see your screen do you
and maybe blow yourself up with a rocket
perhaps cause rockets are big right now
stop standing because hey your titan's
going to drop that bubble man i remember
always just
caught you down so yeah
it's like for atheon and stuff like that
so
yeah i was like if it's my luck i'm not
gonna get vex method glass for a while
so i'm not exactly holding my breath on
the first run
um do you think same as some of these
other weapons we talked about
where do you think the big weapons what
do you think about weapons are going to
be do you think vex is going to be
powerful or are they afraid to make it
too strong is fate bringer still just
going to be the best one and
as you said scouts and snipers are just
going to be another option in the loot
table for the same archetype
the loot's the biggest thing as you said
for cog that makes this
loop this raid special when it launched
because these guns were unlike anything
else
fate bringer automatic solar scout rifle
vex was special for a little while till
it got nerfed into the ground but
to the ground where do you think the
loot is gonna fall from everything that
you get especially when you kill atheon
you know you're gonna be excited about
what you get are you gonna be like it's
another 180 scout cool
like where do you think you're gonna hit
yeah i i think freight bringing it
is gonna be it's gonna be fine i think
if you look at
the artifact mods they even have a mod
this season i believe that
intensifies the firefly dragonfly
perk whatever that perk is that uh
fatebringer does
so yeah i think it's going to be fine
and they remember
even in the meta the uh the sandbox
changes they made
a game what is it dragonfly firefly what
is it what color is the new one coming
like
this season but dragonfly is what we've
had well we've had yeah like
to intensify the explosion and the
radius
and things like that so i'm i'm
expecting
legendary sun shots type status with it
like
sunshine got some love so i mean it
should be
you know equivalent this guy we already
know what it's going to be the one i'm
looking for is vex
vex i'm very curious because
the new bungie seems to
when something's new and debuts they
tend to
go over the line yeah
yeah and they miss really good for a
season
right and then we'll get the 12 next
season okay guys we figured with fusion
we had to pull this back now
you know so i think they understand the
importance of x
and obviously they it was notorious to
deal when it first
launched so i i think we're gonna get
some op level at first
and then they let us have fun with the
season then they'll put it back but vex
is the one man they they've got to do
something cool with it
you know i'm excited to see what th what
they do the other
ones the archetypes are going to be the
key you know
what what the shotgun's going to be you
know what's the other one up again we
got
um i'm sorry but mark they're going to
do your scout dirty i just got it i know
man put it out
we know machine guns should be in a good
place they got a nice little buff
you know so yeah i mean overall i think
they'll be fine mine is like one or two
archetypes and that's gonna see what vex
is gonna do
but that that's the one i want vex and
fabring are the two
that you cannot you kind of can't mess
with that like those are
iconic so we shall see yeah so
i can give you a couple pieces of info
division of confluence
got a 180 scout is that the same as hung
jury
right now jury's 150 i think
yeah jury is is not it's not a good
place at all
so that's you said it's 180 hungary um
yeah they're both 180s yeah vision and
hungary are the same archetype
fatebringer is going to be a 140. that
makes sense
it kind of fits found verdict is an
aggressive frame
oh hard-hitting high recoil shotgun oh
that would be maybe like a pvp option
because those are still very popular
corrective measure is a 450 adaptive
um for a machine gun oh that's a spot
interesting perks on there these
inventions for rocket launcher is also
it's going to be aggressive
that's good that's good that's it that's
in the uh
close to the code is i think there's no
code dwell is high impact but that's the
aggressives are still good
yep so those are the main rockets that
you can kind of
see so yeah i mean it's like
it'll kind of depend on where they fall
in archetypes it's like i'm kind of with
you there as well
it's like fatebringer should be solid
it's got potential with those explosions
that's part of for me though and i think
maybe mark why you
why destiny one still almost feels
better sometimes when it comes to
certain things
certain things destiny 2 is doing better
certain things destiny 1. we've always
go back and forth on this fun little
joke
but when you pick up a fatebringer it
had firefly that was unique to it it had
the oracle modifier right there on it
intrinsically and now i've got to go
into this artifact that pisses me off
because
i've i can i'm looking at 25 mods but i
can't even unlock them all so then if
you do want to then you got to reset it
well do i want to reset it just to toy
around with this like explosion mod 4
fate bringer
is it that good some people are going to
pay to do it so
and then i'm gonna have to go take a mod
off somewhere else just to be able to
try this
so much more goes into just as opposed
to hey this cool weapon drops it's got
some badass stuff to it
sweet right and it's like there's so
much more work to kind of like
unwrap all of the potential of even just
fatebringer as you said with that mod
there taking firefly and making it more
powerful
which is cool but then also for the
oracle disruptor then i go
gotta go get a raid mod on there so i
gotta get vault of glass
armor to make sure i can use the mod you
didn't even have to have vaulted glass
armor to be able to have the oracle
weapons
now you need the armor to be able to use
the weapon to get the oracle disrupter
yeah so like
i'll go ahead i mean it's the raid like
that stuff should just be unlocked dude
that is the pinnacle of destiny man like
that is it
like to me i think back to destiny one
you know
right after vault launched and you could
not be level 30
yes unless you had a full set of vault
of glass gear and i know
that was a hindrance to a lot of people
and it took me a while to finally get to
30
i had the luxury of having people always
run with which i know everybody doesn't
have that
but like in this case like
that that stuff should be unlocked
especially like you know you get the
armor you should automatically have the
armor as ornaments
they should be transmog for you because
you worked you went into the rage you
did that why is that not even a thing
like i saw some people even online
talking about that like i shouldn't have
to synthwave
right isn't that the thing you would
still have to do that if you want that
like no
that is a pinnacle like like the
pinnacle
activity in this game man it should be
you you completed the vaulted glass this
is what you got this week
put that on people know where you got it
people know like wow that guy's a raider
because that
that's what i enjoyed about destiny one
you go back to the tower man you put on
your new gear
you know half the time i even if you
didn't have the full set it's like yeah
i'm walking around with the titan head
and the rest of my armor is you know
purples but
they know well i got one right yeah he
did a yag it was super excited like
and that excitement just seems to have
been lost i agree and some of it
and and i know people have that loss
it's a test ever
well the cool stuff isn't yeah there's
one thing that i wanted to ask
you guys because it's it's speculation
from what i've seen but in like
kind of looking at some of these shaders
the way it
reads on some of the vault of glass
shaders is that
once you beat these once you beat vault
of glass
you can go by the shader in eververse
you know okay in eververse but is that
you have to beat the raid
to unlock the ability to buy it in
eververse
oh so well they've already been doing
that with their jackets and rings you
can buy right when you beat the raid i
mean you're already spending a couple
hundred dollars on that
but what is the the shaders are those um
is it shadow white like chinese or
something silver or are they purchased
is some of the shaders i know they're up
to 300 bright dust now are those bright
dust
i hope so because it's like if i beat
the raid i shouldn't have to pay silver
at least what's going on because
everybody's got it
shouldn't that one just be like hey you
beat vog totally
yeah yeah it should just be a shader but
it shouldn't be like now you can go spin
some bright dust hope you have
someone the thing that that is
acceptable for is
if you get vog and they're selling an
ornament for
for um with the class that's it yeah
yeah eyes of tomorrow they've done that
with exotics which i don't have a
problem
with the ornament but i better not be
going to test
to go cop be a child chat away that
that's not a good look that is not
a good look i was like language
somewhere i've read this about these
shaders and vivid chat knows what i'm
talking about
i read that and i was just jaw dropped i
was like are you
are you kidding like you're gonna wow
the i mean
then like you've taken like deep stone
crypt out of pinnacles and now you've
like
shot vog in the foot for uh
and but as like so you're like you gotta
earn the gun then you gotta make sure
you get the mod for the weapon
then you got to put that mod on the
armor then when you beat vog you're
going to unlock the ability to go to
everest to buy it and you're just like
ugh that's not even though
it doesn't even sound like the same
parade anymore that sounds crazy no
i just thought about something what
about this where's what i want
now remember one of the the glory days
was age of triumph oh man now if they if
they're smart
they bring that exact design back for
like hard mode or
challenge mode to get a special look
remember you have the wi-fi yeah i wanna
look
at everything when i come back to the
tower so
they need to bring it back they got the
designs and the thing that's been
frustrating for me is especially when i
look at like
we talk about people being again but
when you look at iron banner mark and
remember
that that hollow fire chest kind of
thing and yeah
[Music]
we named our podcast iron little podcast
because of this damn game that's how
boss you looked when you had that iron
band again
like i want to feel like i conquered
something
and they have the assets people would be
okay with them
using those assets like reuters yes
those those are iconic agent triumph
and remember the um the the was that the
crota one was was
beast too oh you had like the green
little glows that like
came out of the shoulders you had the
like kind of floating cubes from axis
from rise of iron uh and then crota
king's fall was kind of like the the
whitish glow off of the dark armor
and then crota was the one with like the
green like wavy gold
yeah and that's kind of one of those
things it's like
okay so if you beat that's where again
comes to the incentive
hey if you do go do master difficulty
when that comes out in july or whenever
it drops
you can earn ornaments for this you can
now earn universal ornaments that you
can use anywhere by beating this
difficulty
if that's in there that's at least
something that people be like these look
amazing
and you get something or you know that
whole grind hey we put some of these in
the game if they don't put
some of that stuff in the game behind
some of these difficulties
that's those are some real questionable
decisions at that point
mm-hmm preach it reach it
come help us yeah we we are at a very
that's why i was like
i am very curious where the dust settles
at with vault of glass first this
weekend
but then after the difficulties and
everything to know what's in eververse
what's in
the difficulties how the challenges fall
because i want to know
where this is going to explain kind of a
lot because then which queen is
which queen is your next raid yeah and
this may tell the story of how that's
that's the end of this trilogy that is
the start of the end the beginning of
the end per se that is the final three
years
and witch queen is about as big as oryx
for d1
which queen is savathoon putting all the
dominoes together whatever the epilogue
is gonna do season 15 leads into that
which we still don't have a clue
i core is going to be hugely important
to that i mean there's a lot coming
marisov still floating out there there's
so much that leans on that one
but then if you turn around and you feel
like this is the way the model of
the raid is going to work with you know
get this armor get these mods put this
in here
intrinsic weapons don't even have
anything anymore then ever versus where
most of the stuff's at you're like
it sometimes sucks the life out of it
for me and like for you especially it's
like
if like what i always wonder it's like
when is somebody like you finally gonna
be like
i just can't anymore i know you've taken
big breaks and you know you play other
stuff and i've honestly haven't really
breaks me i was like i've had a
healthier relationship these past
probably
18 months you know almost two years
whatever like when i started going
much more variety when i streamed like
that has kept me sane and healthy it's
like i'll still
do a lot of destiny content those are
guides those are things here but it's
been the
variety that's helped me it's like is
there some of those decisions if i'm
like i can't
yeah i mean you know for me man like i
said it was always
logging in getting those new well i say
what what kept me coming back outside of
just a podcast was like getting
these new places to explore and this new
stuff to experience and instead
you know just the the constant grind for
new mods to
you know just do the harder difficulty
content just kind of
fizzled out for me you know i just kind
of lost the the drive to keep doing that
and
that's kind of where i am with it now so
i i log in you know when the new
expansions come out i
purchased every single one check out
those new story contents like i said
last season
didn't even buy any of the seasons this
season i bought the season pass and
i'm usually there the day that it
launches check out kind of what's new
and then
you know just kind of falling away i've
checked in like last season for the
first
three weeks i think i was there every
tuesday and kind of keeping up with it
and then
kind of fizzled out dipped back every
once in a while and then this season i
mean i played last tuesday
um but i didn't play this tuesday you
know so i don't know
well part of that is because i'm totally
you know hanging out in a galaxy
with uh a little commander shepard and
kind of doing all that reliving all that
stuff again
do i want this amazing incredible story
that i'm kind of reliving again or
do i just want to go you know grind the
same content over and over and over
i'm going to do some mass effect so
that's that's got my time right now but
um that mass effect is glorious right
yep
if you've never played mass effect go
play it guys
no no i know i have never actually
touched it so that's why i was like i
haven't downloaded i'm ready it's like
i'm just trying to find the right time
because
i got to a point where i waited long
enough and then there was this like
rumor like they were going to do a
remaster i was like well i gotta wait
for that
so now finally at some point and i was
like you know got bio mutant coming out
literally on tuesday and stuff so
there's some cool stuff i want to check
out and that one looks
that one looks like a really cool single
player you know crazy it looks like
rocket raccoon kung fu adventure so
the best way i can describe it just kind
of goofy um yeah
so that one's fun but it's like in some
of the the downtime and places
no that that's a must and that's just
one of those for me because i want to
play on stream and things of that nature
that's like
i just gotta pick like my fairly open
like wednesdays usually i got some time
and that's just gonna start to be like
just the wednesday play through and just
work through the whole thing because
i have heard between so many people you
guys
and then even one of my best friends
doesn't even he will skip
story cut scenes and literally just a
beeline through every game he ever plays
which you know sometimes bugs me still
one of his favorite games and i'm like
if it gets
him like then it's like okay i know so i
got i got i mean it's
it's like imagine i mean destiny
launched and sure they had created
somewhat of a universe but it was very
obtuse and you had to you know going to
the grimoire and
now we're at a point where you know the
world and all that of of destiny
but it took a while to get there mass
effect like from day one i mean i
remember reading the prequel novel
and then like when you jump into it dude
there is like they created that world
and the universe and history and
everything before they even did the game
yeah and when you the first game still
i'll tell you it feels a little bit
dated but like
but you're there for the story man
you're there for that world and it just
it feels lived in and
i mean by the time you get to two two is
like one of the greatest games of all
time
baby that's what i'm talking about the
story is incredible so like it's
especially being if you're a star wars
fan because yeah this is the same team
that did
star wars knights the old republic and
they didn't want to pay for the license
anymore do the licensing with star wars
so they said
okay we're going to create our own our
own universe and that's what they did
and mass effect is
the trilogy amazing andromeda is its own
beast
for now stay away from andromeda you
know it's it's it's the best effect of
that
the trilogy is incredible i agree i
agree yeah it's absolutely man world
building
from the minute you know when i knew it
was something different just a minute
you open up the kodak and you hear the
narrator telling you
about these races about relationships
about the like just
just so much great world building like
it's tremendous character oh it's
ee believe me i know i'm going to stay
with you with this
here's something i'm going to tell you
too man right now it's kind of a shout
out to another podcast but
let's go before this came out a couple
weeks ago i just was looking for
some mass effect stuff there's a podcast
called the mass effect lorecast
of course okay he's only like maybe
seven eight episodes in but he has kind
of a network of other kind of lore shows
yeah he's they're crushing it dude like
every like it totally has just made my
replaying of this
oh i gotta watch that much better now if
you you know there are spoilers
obviously because he's kind of they're
going through everything about each race
and all that so
being someone who's played it before
it's made this play through now just
that much better
so if people are listening to this if
you haven't checked it out the mass
effect lorecast i think robots is the
guy's name that runs it
um go check it out it's awesome it's
great each episode is like 45 50 minutes
long focuses on
one of the races gets into all their
history and it just blows my mind
the history that is there for this game
it's
it's awesome now breaking breaking news
uh shadow boys of course on top of it
challenge xp clarification says it
dropped literally zero hours ago
apparently this morning
uh so i'm just gonna read this video
to everybody watching the world uh we've
noticed some confusion around
seasonal challenge xp payouts this
season wanted to clear up some
miscommunication on our part
first there was a bug last season where
players who had earned xp bonuses from
season 12
season 12 season pass did not have these
bonuses reset
at the start of season 13. this
carryover resulted in season 13
challenges paying out much greater
experience than intended
i did actually wonder every so often to
get like two levels from one challenge
rather than opt to fix the bug
mid-season we decided to leave
it in place and let players continue to
benefit from it we mistakenly
did not acknowledge this during season
13 and we missed it in the 3.2.0 patch
for 14.
the challenge the change did call out
the change we did call out in 3.2.0
patch
was the addition of new xp payout size
for seasonal challenges
called extra-large xp this payout is
comparable to the amount of xp that
players
need to earn to complete half a season
pass rank with the addition
of x these extra large xp payouts we
also changed the overall naming
convention
the reason we moved to the new naming
convention was to better highlight that
the xp
payouts from the challenges were larger
than from other bounties and activities
that show xp as a reward
we did not clearly explain this change
nor was the new naming convention easy
to understand
these name changes led to confusion as
players began tackling the week 1
challenges we understood and agree we
understand and agree that season 14 name
changes are confusing
and the team is looking to update the
names for clarity in a future patch
for the time being here's a quick look
at how seasonal challenge xp payouts
have been updated
so in season 13 it's blank is now
extra-large so it's
half a rank uh season 13 was xp now it's
two times xp so that's
1.0 ranks season 14 is
times four extra large xp that's two
ranks and then 4x xp which is times
eight extra large xp it's four ranks
it may fluctuate depending on xp bonuses
and stuff like that
seasonal challenges are still your go to
go to source for consistent xp
players who complete all seasonal
challenges will still exceed level 11
in the season or level 100 in the season
pass we know
xp in destiny can be confusing shocking
sometimes to the point that we miss
things ourselves
we apologize for the confusion of these
changes and
in all all in all between the shifts of
the seasonal xp challenge
payouts and xp bonus bug we expect
players to earn xp and progress through
the season pass at a similar rate to
they did in season 12.
we'll keep an eye on data and your
feedback and let you know if we make any
changes for see
this season or in season 15. just when
we were talking about xp bugs and things
like that that came up
here's a little bit of about it like
it's more clarification
but yeah like i kind of actually wanted
to ask you as
you jump back every so often is that new
seasonal challenge model versus the like
weekly bounties and stuff like that
is that something that like do you like
that one where you can come back and
catch up do you even care about the
difference
don't even know it's there no well i
know i mean i know it's there but i
don't even really
like it really engage with it like
everyone's on my thing will pop up and
say like hey you got some stuff on your
season pass i go in there and it's like
oh your your glimmer is full you can't
use it until you you know it always
gives you like those
you know you get like uh i mean what
else is in there and graham's right you
get some engrams trapping
the season pass this is the seasonal
challenges like the new
quest tab stuff where it's like oh right
though oh okay that's what this is
working towards so there you go so again
i'm not even engaging really in any of
this at all so
yeah no ma'am yeah any thoughts on the
nice little xp
issue yeah it was it was weird like i i
was like you know shout out to the
breaking news but
yeah it was weird you know they they've
had this error which given out more than
intended you know they leaving it as is
for now i guess so to speak and then
clarifying how they're gonna change the
terminology of
of the thing you know not too big a deal
for me i mean
you know just i just think it's
housekeeping honestly yeah you know they
just wanted to put us up to but i don't
i don't think this is gonna do
do you like the new seasonal challenges
how they've been so far are you like
okay with them good bad otherwise where
are you feeling where they landing for
you are they like
a nice change or kind of just
you know same thing different title same
thing different title i think some
things have hit
the thing that i've been paying
attention more has been
a bounty acquisition for like bigger
quests
where they have this you know step three
of this stuff you know i've been liking
seeing the optional thing where it's
like do this or this
like past destiny would say hey get
fusion rifle kills
yeah you know what i'm saying and do
this and then it's like okay if you
don't want to do it
then you're kind of frustrated you know
if you or you hate that archetype
now it's like okay do fusion rifle kills
or you know solar solar subclass kind of
thing
and i i prefer that so i'm not locked in
the same thing with strikes and things
of that nature that's
that's mundane so i prefer when these
options given now one that
didn't give an option that i was mad was
when i did banner this week oh dear
and i'm doing that quest and i full
confession
mark i never snipe
ever ever when a sniping quest comes up
i'm like
not doing it like i just i've i've never
had
or what what's the one the one that
adorned did not
adore i'm just i'm not a sniper
intrinsically i just don't gravitate
towards it right
shame on me i get to the final step of
venom
and it's like mandatory
ten sniper kills and i'm like
you gotta be kidding me right now you
gotta be kidding me to my credit
you did it i i bust out cloud strike
and caught me two sheep
multi kills at a control spot and
it was pumping my it was so hard for me
to do this like
it was a challenge bro like i am
terrible
with that like i realized how awful it i
was but i gave it credit it helped me
learn a little bit but
i just hate when they lock you in
sometimes especially when it's something
you cannot stand or something you
do not use yes back for that revoke a
quest i i just said you know what
that's good i'm never gonna own god
bless everyone who got it you did it
you don't say i i just won't know about
it like that's just me like when it
comes to
intrusity i'm just not my play style is
not to sit back
and do it just not but i pat myself on
the back
i actually did this one but cloud strike
was the key
i was like go watch cool guys he'll
terrify you with clubs right clown shy
okay but yeah that's the only one just
change that verb
but for the most part they've been good
lately they've been good about giving
more options than in these questions
stuff like that so that's all i really
care about everything else has been
typical destiny what about you what are
you feeling about this whole thing
it's okay i feel like i actually had a
decent amount of bright dust last season
i didn't do all of them
biggest reason there was a point where
like hey you know it's it's a double
triple get infamy week or whatever so
it's like and you got to you know get
five ranks and get in gambit infinite
you got to go all the way through like
the full 15k or whatever it is i'm like
okay we're gonna spend some time in
gambit you know it's a time to just
stream and chill and kind of just it's
an easy way to chat with everybody
because i'm mindlessly playing gambit so
it's a nice thing for just like
mindless playing on screen chatting with
everybody kind of hanging out with the
community and stuff
and then like weeks later it said hey
now you got to get 40
um invader kills in gambit and it was
not
retroactive at all and i was done
so any if it's like if it connects a
season so and the thing is it's weird
some is retroactive
some's not and i'm like that's weird you
either
like just give them that's why i was
like i saw something come up for gambit
i'm like not touching it until that
whole season's open and if i go play
gambit i'm going to do it one time
because especially talk about a mode
like crucible hasn't been touched that
is like the redheaded stepchild of
crucible
um so it's stuff like that that like you
know the season pass you go through and
it's usually like hey do these basic
story challenges
use a couple guns get a decent chunk of
experience and some currency
not bad but then when you have to do
gambit then it's like hey you grinded
this thing out which was like
way too many hours and then you gotta go
do it again that doesn't feel good so
that type of stuff needs to sit a little
bit better to make sure it's like it's
either retroactive which i know they can
track and look at
um and be like if it popped up it's like
hey you got like 20 kills you're halfway
there would be like all right at least
you know what i did i put some time in
now i can go focus on invasions
you know go be the annoying guy with
xenophage and piss a few people off be
done with it
but if it was just zeros like i'm out so
those moments for me are just some of
those weird things
that it's like hey oh nope and that's
that's been the story for probably the
entire time you've been talking about
this game it's like
occasionally step forward step back two
steps forward one step back yeah
yeah two steps forward to the side or
backwards twice with like transmog it's
like it's always this little box step
dance that they do and they cannot seem
to just always
nail everything same thing with the raid
when we're talking about and i wanted to
read this tweet out of tassie's
that cracked me up what tasks he said uh
it was
yeah it was yesterday so he's like i
need to reset crucible valor
can't because i'm full of prisms can't
buy a shard with prisms because i'm full
of shards
spin the shards on mediocre exotic can't
buy a shard because he doesn't have the
50 000 glimmer
go to spider to buy glimmer buy a shard
collect prisms collect shard reset
crucible valor i'm like
jeez man jesus paul
cause you have to go through and like
take every
reward before you can reset and pull the
other thing but if you're sitting there
with currency because you're like i
don't want to just dump it into crap
and then if you don't have the glimmer
to buy the i was just i laughed at that
one because i've been through that exact
same step and i just had to call it out
it's one of those weird ones
so yeah and then like there's aries it's
like i delete prisms when i can't get
them from vendors it's just like
it's there are and then now the fact
with unsun setting we are
like everybody's talking about felt
space once again because now that's
being a cap for those of us who like to
hold on to things it's being an issue
because now we can keep it forever
there's there tends to be this good and
bad so it's like having a healthy
relationship with this game
not living it anymore has honestly been
sounds like
a good thing for you because you know
it's freed up your world but also a good
thing for
totally for me as well it's like making
it like you know your tuesday reset keep
up with the story and then sometimes not
even tuesdays if it's going to be like
week 12 this season when there's not
much going on
i'm gonna be diet that's like just mass
effect for the whole damn week and
that's what those times are for
so that's good yeah and you know like
you said earlier
you know cognito like destiny when it's
good man like
it has its hooks on you and we know
it'll be good again you know it's like
so
they're always you have those moments
where hey maybe it is just your tuesday
game
but there's going to come a time you
know in the future that this is going to
be your absolutely
play for days you know play for hours on
days it's it's just
it's absolutely to me like i said i feel
as a gamer i'm in a healthier place like
i
i'm playing a for more variety of my
games you know what i'm saying and then
i'll have my three to four day lockdown
period when i'm really working on
something that's
i really want something or something
really appeals to me in the meta
and for right now the only thing i did
is i just prepped
for um vault and like what i'm gonna
come in there with right
and i think right now i love the
artifacts set up
ever like with a lot of a lot of mods
for warming cell builds
and i'm really gonna i'm gonna i'm
really liking what i'm seeing especially
on
the rocket launcher stuff i'm seeing a
lot of um
void splash damage stuff so i got some
builds in my mind that i'm like yeah i
wanna i wanna try this stuff out
when i get in there but once i get that
then i'm like okay i'm good
time for mass effect time for this game
time for that game
and i feel good man it's it's good to
have a healthy balance when it
doesn't have your you know the hooks in
it and you just can't but
i mean but when it's good i don't stop
but i have a blast so
yeah that's where i'm at with it yep
yeah you don't need to be upset
and be angry like how i used to be it's
it's it's
a better that less stressful life man
i hope if there's any takeaway anybody
ever got from guardian radio that's what
it was i mean we
we got accused of being bungee shills
always because of it but it was just
like man
we're just it's a video game we're
having fun and if you're not having fun
go play something else for a little bit
and come back like you'll be good it'll
be good man like don't
don't worry about it you'll have fun
again in this game i promise you keep
keeping the community keep having fun
with your friends and
yes yeah you guys will come back to it
when when it's good for sure i agree
so i absolutely agree yeah can't end
that one on much of a better note
so yeah we got to make sure this man can
get to his day we got him back his life
but we did want to wrap up and just say
first off thank you for joining us 150
from milestone man i mean come on 150
man
dude thank you thank you like that's
that's a big one i was like you were
literally
like guardian radio was my first actual
podcast listen
first one and since then i listened to
way too many now so i was like
i do like podcasts are like cleaning
walking dog getting up in the woods
exactly man all the time like they're
always and it's a nice way to take in
information or catch up on all those
types of things
of course new red had to do that oh real
regular
sponsorship yep so yeah but
while cognito does his thing i wanted to
give you the floor and he may interrupt
you but that's just part of the whole
joke here
um for you for anybody who doesn't know
you somehow missed out on the world of
what you may have done before but what
you're doing now let them know where to
find you what you got going on
anything cool you got planned if they
can find you in your stupid stormtrooper
outfit
where you might be like all of that
best place follow me on twitter at
markturkmrkturc
uh i do the show the enthusiast life can
be found on you know all the podcasts
feeds it's on uh i come out every year
every monday through friday so every
weekday sometimes on the weekend
sometimes i'll have a guest
um i kind of call it a little i mean
it's kind of my own word but like a plug
like a podcast vlog it bounces back
they're doing some sit-ups
you know it's just me just talking about
things that i'm enthusiastic about from
video games comics
movies tv all that stuff and uh
you know if you follow me on twitter you
can see all just uh i've been playing a
lot of
he mentioned it earlier a little bit of
marvel champions man awesome card game i
promise you i've gotten kind of into
some table top games here over the past
year so this game if it's the first
i mean it's a card game but the first
board game that i've actually played
solo now i know that sounds crazy i'm
going to tell people that because
through the pandemic obviously we're
going to be getting together with people
but
yeah a board game solo i'm like really
and people in my
in my my patreon members in my discord
were like no man it's great it's great
so i jumped into it it is a fully
customizable every time you play it is
different
and wow it's super fun trust me it feels
a little bit weird to play it solo but
it is kind of now competing with my
video game time if i have 30 minutes
it's like do i want to sit down and play
mass effect or maybe do a couple uh you
know halo matches or
do i want to go run a you know a battle
between
you know groot versus rhino or do i want
to run you know captain marvel verse
versus uh kang like what do i want to do
like this game
i i'm telling you guys it's crazy go
watch some videos on it watch some
videos
another crazy thing i'm doing i mean
just mentioned i'm a pharmacist so this
past year has just been
bananas or some of the things i've
gotten to do from you know covet testing
and all that but
in a week and a half if you live in the
charlotte area which i know probably
many people don't
uh i'm going to be giving covet shots
wow at a nascar race the bank of america
or i'm sorry the cochlear 600 here in
charlotte
at the walmart booth there's gonna be a
walmart booth at the race if you want to
get your covet shot from me
storm troopers we usually miss our shots
this shot ain't gonna be missed i'll
definitely be giving you your shots if
you're looking to get your vaccine i can
do that for you
at a nascar race which i'm like what
when what world would i ever be doing
that like
sitting in front of a nascar you know
track at a nascar event giving shots and
part of it i was telling my texts like
guardiancon and destinycom one of the
best parts about it was just like
mingling with the people
and i'm sure that's what we're gonna be
doing i said we're probably not even
gonna be giving that many vaccines we're
just gonna be like
hanging out you know talking to the
people all there is promoting like
health and wellness in that so i'm
looking forward to that man it's gonna
be a lot of fun here
that's memorial day weekend we're gonna
be doing that so
that is really cool bro that's it for me
man wow
tremendous man good to have you back man
like love
seeing the growth love seeing you just
doing the different things you love
salute to you with that for a good cause
man get getting the uh
vaccine shots everybody ready and um
that's i mean
what a better like you can't make that
combination
because we've been i mean we've been
doing clinics now for the last couple
months and all that going to you know
nursing homes or just even in our store
we've been doing it
but then you know i see this email come
across and it was like hey we need
two pharmacists and two techs to do the
nascar races so i looked at my partner i
was with i was like if you ever been to
a nascar race and she was like no i was
like
do you want to do this i was like
because you're living in charlotte i
mean i've been to
some races here which i never was in a
nascar until we moved here
but they're just super fun you know it's
really just a big party is all it is
and so she was like yeah then two of our
techs we were working with they're like
i've never been i'm like well let's do
it i was like let's tell them the only
way we'll do it is if
because they're doing it actually friday
saturday sunday i was like the only way
we'll do it is if it's the actual
like the big the big sunday race and so
we're doing it
it's gonna be wild but it's it's gonna
be fun it's gonna be a lot of fun
definitely you gotta put some picks up
with something that sounds amazing yeah
that's kind of awesome
that's gonna be fun very
i've been stuck here in the carolinas
now for almost 15 years but
mm-hmm sounds crazy man lots of crazy
things it seems to be treating you all
right though
oh yeah definitely we love it what about
you sir
cognito the lord of the round table
yeah man the same old stuff man i'll be
back on iron lord's podcast this sunday
with the rest of the lords we'll have
our mr maddie plays we'll be
in the realm we're going to be talking
about little e3 hype we're seeing what's
going on with the consoles
probably talk xbox or maybe some star
field talk some ps5 talk and um
just getting ready as we count down the
weeks before e3
kind of predictions and stuff like that
so the hype train's starting to get
going so check us out sunday 1 p.m
eastern
on ireland podcast on youtube check us
out also lords of gaming.net
some great articles we're doing as a eu
scene and we're doing this thing called
the lord's minute
but we get one of the lawyers we're the
writer we have like a hot button topic
sometimes destiny is in there we got a
good one right now mass effect with
inclusion please
it's actually up now i just i did that
with um
knit with ty great stuff we talk a lot
about mass effect stuff like that
um yeah man it's been real cool so yeah
everybody if you could support lords of
gaming.net
really appreciate a good opinion pieces
by a great team of writers
and of course man that that last word
podcast we're 1
50 150 guys it's big deal
it's been it's been a minute since curse
of osiris and our yeah
the worst time to start a podcast ever
for destinations
always something to talk about dude
that's what i've told you like destiny
is podcast gold you can always have
something to talk about something to
talk about that's one thing but
destiny is the gift that keeps giving
because either they do something the
community does something
yeah there's always something with dusty
but um yeah yeah with a shout out yeah
man cause
this is this is cool 150 didn't think
you know we still be
rocking as consistent and still going as
we are
and i just thought about something now
that we got mark here um
could kirk be from roy when we
met i feel it was not that far from the
guardian radio booth if not at the
moment in radio section i don't when i
met you for the first time i feel like
you and i bumped each to each other in
the fall like the back
where there was a line up where there
was like the lineup of like going
through and kind of getting like
autographs or talking to the specific
people who were sitting in the booths
okay i know you and i also caught each
other though outside passing out
business cards because we were the two
people doing that we had only two people
one person has that thing yeah i was
like you know we bumped into
it to each other doing that but then i
remember seeing you later on the inside
as well so
kind of talking a little bit in there
but yeah no all the way back to
you know tampa florida sweaty crazy
thing
hot tampon man crazy i love hearing men
and i just it always just i don't know
this is this is the one thing stepping
away from guardian radio that like
looking back on it and i
i just i love hearing it is i mean you
said it about this even you said a cog
needle like
guardian radio was your first podcast i
don't know what it was about like that
time and place maybe we just were
magic i mean we were in the right place
at the right time but like i hear that
so many times from people and i that
just makes me
so happy like people didn't even know
podcasts were a thing and like the fact
that i was able to just cause just one
little spark in some people and then to
look at you guys
what you've been doing 150 episodes in
you know i'm incognito doing other
podcasts i mean about
your youtube channel all that dudes i
mean thank you for having me i i love
you know coming back to this community
because it really uh i don't know
so this is great i appreciate it i
appreciate hearing things like that man
i really do
yeah you guys oh geez man you guys oh
geez in the space and
it was always it was always cool to to
see like yo that can be done
like and and and being inspiring to a
lot in the community you guys don't
realize you influence so
many and again it was so cool to have
you for this one because i'm like oh we
got vlogs we got the whole gen here
we go and then it's also refreshing to
hear your perspective
as someone from who's been away for a
while yeah you know just
to see what you're doing and stuff like
that and even you we've had this
discussion like every once in a while
like hey
we're talking about other games we talk
about other stuff because otherwise
you don't want to get to the point yeah
you get burnt out and then you just get
all angry at everything and it's just
like
you know that's what you need to break
so a wise man he bought his topic
it's okay it's okay to play with the
games right it's okay
it's okay even luke smith says that so
yeah exactly
as for me again mark thank you very much
for coming on always a pleasure having
you it's
like i feel like it's one of those
that's like barely i was like the intro
i wanted to make sure and do justice
there but i was like as for
like this man can talk i don't have to
worry about like cover and run a show or
just it's gonna roll it's like so easy
like and it's just one of those like he
he does this in his time but i wanted to
shout you out as well because i was
catching up on some of your enthusiasts
life
shouted us out on there saying you were
going to be on man like not even
required at all just be like hey i'm
going to be on the last word pod like in
yours i'm like
thank you like that's professional like
this man i know but like that type of
kindness is like
it's and it's just like you never asked
not at all and it was just like i was
just like i was blown away and i just
like and
just think like went from when i met you
there
from like talking to you like when we
were having wings the night before
and all that stuff since then you've
always been just an awesome guy and it's
like and it's always a pleasure to have
you on so
can't say it enough um all right you're
welcome man
as for me
shout out to advanced.gigi i got my
partnership this week so now you guys
can awesome
congrats um 10 off if you guys ever have
questions about flavors
anything i have to get up sometimes in
the morning like literally this morning
it was 4 30 in the morning started my
day with that to make it through a
couple classes so
it's tell that product whether it's
energy or focus if you've got questions
about it you guys know where to go but
use codyboxes to check out
i can finally say that so that was
actually a pretty cool announcement for
me this week on wednesday and thank you
guys who showed up for that one so
yeah that is all i got but for this
episode um
thank you for joining us of course go
follow these gentlemen
check out enthusiasts live check out the
iron lords podcast check them out great
content all across this board today so
you guys are all amazing we're gonna go
raid somebody after this but for
everybody in chat
episode number one five zero
closed it down with an epic guest thank
you guys
and it for this episode it has been
the last word